[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
Royals
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thanks
hmm
[Music]
ings
foreign
[Music]
thank you
nothing is faster and more exhilarating
in chess than a bullet game it's all
about quick thinking and taking
advantage of every opportunity when it
comes blink and you'll miss it how did
he do that despite its popularity bullet
chess only has one annual championship
tournament and now entering its fifth
year the bullet Chess Championship is
stronger than ever three-time Champion
Hikaru Nakamura again looks to defend
his title and add to his impressive
trophy case a brutal finish Nakamura
officially has won the only player who
has ever stopped Nakamura in this event
also returns to take another shot at it
2021 Champion alireza farugia that's it
competing with these champions for the
first time in the format the best
all-around player in the world Magnus
Carlson has dominated chess seemingly
forever but he's never played in the
bullet Chess Championship will one of
these big three of bullet take home the
twenty thousand dollar crown or can
someone else claim the title maybe Nara
ditsky Tang Hansen Carolina
in this speediest of speed chess
championships only one Champion will
emerge
welcome to the 2023 bullet Chess
Championship
[Music]
welcome back it is day two of the 2023
bullet Chess Championship I'm your host
Grandmaster Robert Hess alongside me my
good friend Grandmaster Simon Williams
and boy what an exhilarating day we had
yesterday it ended on a high note it was
Jose Martinez outlasting Anish giri in
sudden death Simon do you expect more of
the same here for day two
uh hi Robert hi everyone watching um I
do I think actually today there's going
to be even more action uh yesterday was
a great start we saw a lot of players
overwhelming uh their opponents
including Hikaru who got a monstrous
score and uh also Magnus Carlson playing
against Eric Hansen you mentioned this
match at the end though Robert and uh
that was one hell of a matchup Jose
Martinez overcoming Anish giri in the
last game possible so uh I think there's
gonna be a lot of close games today
right
it was an incredible first day of action
and we entered the event with 16
participants and guess what that's where
we remain don't worry if your favorite
player lost yesterday you could still
watch them right here right now because
this is a 16 player double elimination
tournament there is a lot of prize money
at stake one hundred thousand dollars
ten of the players were invited directly
into the competition six players had to
qualify their way slugging through the
competition just in those qualifiers to
make it here but when you make it here
it's not all peaches and Roses you have
to win your matches and when Hikaru
Nakamura is in this field the winner of
three of the first four bullet chess
championships you know your work is cut
out for you
you certainly do I mean it's going to be
very tough and as you mentioned Robert I
mean the first games they're gonna be
really really stressful for the players
because uh it is a double elimination
tournament and uh the first matches we
have if they lose they go home they're
out of the competition yesterday they
had a bit of a buffer they lose they get
a second chance but it's it's now
elimination time so that adds to the
tension
it certainly does because while we have
16 players still in the field today four
of these players will not be here
tomorrow you see those players down in
the losers bracket but we start up top
with our four really great matchups
Hikaru Nakamura who was the heavy hitter
yesterday 22 and a half points that was
really a sight to see he takes on Jose
Martinez uh Daniel nerdinsky Andrew tank
that must be the Marquee matchup of
today that one is very close they played
over 3 300 games against each other and
Magnus Carlson he takes up minlay Magnus
himself said that he's been impressed by
men's play and Ali razor first of the
2021 Champion he is going to have a
slugfest against OLX under Bortnick
who's been bought a strong ever since
the first BCC but Simon we have the
losers bracket first that we're gonna
see today these players they do not want
to go home
no of course not they they want to fight
it out all the way and that it's just
some mouth-watering uh prospects already
today but the losers bracket we're
starting off um with Fabiano on his Last
Chance Saloon and he's playing the young
that is lasovic so that's gonna be very
interesting I think is our first match
Fabiano well we know how strong he is
but uh the young Dennis is playing so so
well and we've got many other very
exciting matches in in this chance where
they they don't get another chance if
they lose they they are out but you
mentioned some of those names as well
Robert I mean Hikaru Magnus Daniel
Andrew Tang it's you know what more can
we wish for as chess fans anything I
don't think so
I don't think so either and they don't
have to wish for much longer because the
action will start soon and we're
starting the day as you mentioned
Fabiano caruana taking on Dennis lazovic
Dimitri on draken taking on David
paravian so we have two super Grand
Masters on the right hand side of your
screen but then we have this junior
upstart from Belarus and lazovic and
David paravian who could hold his own in
bullet so we see luzvick on screen here
Simon big expectations for the junior
player
he's been playing so well recently
Robert I mean in the Champions chess
tour which is only just finished he won
division two so he's gonna be in the top
division in the next event so he's on
fire form wise at this moment in time
he's very hard to beat he's got a very
mature style for only 17 years old but
obviously he's playing against Fabiano
and uh I I think the one thing he's got
on his side the well I'm going to say
the only chance he's got because Fabiano
is a better chess player let's be honest
is the clock he's got a way quicker than
Fabiano to have any chance there
I agree with that and he's very
consistent is luzvick he drew 13 games
in a row against super Grand Master sam7
in that Champion's chest tour division
two so that is as consistent as it gets
but somebody who did not have a good day
yesterday but we know is a superstar in
his own right is Dimitri on draken he
made the candidates way back in 2014
he's been a super Grand Master uh for a
decade
33-10 Peak bullet rating on chess.com he
was a finalist in the rapid Chess
Championship a year ago and I think
maybe this is his most impressive stat
at all 13 time winner of title Tuesday
Robert that's just greedy you know you
know he should share them about a little
bit give me one of them just one of them
there's you know that's the only chance
I would have of ever winning a title
Tuesday
um and what a play here so I mean
Dimitri has been on chess.com playing
these tournaments for as long as I can
remember and he's always been at the top
he's always been challenging for the
prizes and uh he just has an amazing
track record he is an elite player and
he's pretty good at all time limits as
well
yeah he certainly is but so is his
opponent because he's taking on David
paravian who's made a name for himself I
think he's one of the biggest
beneficiaries of Chess being online
because he's had great success in the
rapid Chess Championship in speed chess
events so it's good to see pravian here
but you know he doesn't want to just be
here he wants to move on and he takes on
on Drake and that's going to be a
difficult matchup for him but this is a
determined player this is somebody who
has succeeded against higher rated
opposition so Simon I think that
Province certainly has a chance and he
may not even be so much of an underdog
uh agreed I think it's going to be quite
a close match we saw David play very
quickly yesterday and again I think he's
got to use the clock
um I mean that goes without saying
really but it does coming more
importantly and we saw that maybe adri
Aiken's sort of weakness yesterday was
the clock
um he
in the super quick Andrew tang and I
think anyone would have a problem
against Andrew in the clock but this is
uh going to be an important factor in
that match as well great startup matches
for us because again we've got to remind
everyone if they lose they go home
they're out of the competition and
they're and some of the other parents
after that though I mean they're
mouth-watering as well
I'm gonna put you on the spot quickly
predictions for our opening two matchups
who is going to move on
I'm gonna go Fabiano and I'm gonna go
Dimitri and what about yourself wow
you're going with the super GMS I am
going to go with Fabiano I do think that
he will right the ship from yesterday's
debacle but he was playing bornick and
I'm gonna go with pravian I think pravin
is that good he impressed me yesterday
against Dania he took five and a half
points off of the legendary Sensei and
Prophet nariditski so I think that
paravian I think he'll take
watch it
I think my my guesses are a bit
unoriginal there I just literally went
for the higher rated players you know it
was it was quite an easy call and this
is what I do quite generally it's
nothing special about my predictions
often um but they could be very close as
you say I feel the second match
be the closer one uh but whatever
happens today I think all the matches
have more potential to go to the wire
and so are we going to see more tie
breaks do you think
oh I definitely think we will
in first two matches but it's the
Marquee matchup the one that I labeled
as such between tang and nariditsy I
could see that going on forever and that
match is going to be so close
yes uh that that match I think everyone
must be excited about but we actually
start to see some moves on the board now
okay and they are already speeding
through the opening stages we have a
night orph on the right hand side of our
screen between uh actually it's not a
night over because the Pawn's not an A6
excuse me between paravian and andrakin
and the left-hand side we have lusvic
with white against Fabiano and that
looks like a King's Inn in a closed
position so when you see them out of the
gate Simon do you you know notice
anything about maybe their styles for
the day or what are you taking away from
the opening stage
well the only thing I can say very
quickly is Fabiano is playing a very
blocked position he probably realizes
the structure he's going for should be a
bit worse for black he's winning the
exchange here uh quite risky but I think
against a younger opponent it's a good
idea to keep the position blocked
because you you give them maybe less
tactical chances and more chances of
using your experience
um but what's going on there uh Robert
already a lot of tactics on the board
yeah Mayhem ensues and we see uh in the
Fabiano Gamers Dennis loves it well it
was Advantage for white but that King on
H2 looks like it's in a bit more danger
than the King on Jade that said mistakes
are going to continue to happen and wow
I can't even calculate quickly enough
things are flying off the board
it's absolutely Mayhem and if this is uh
how the match is gonna go we're in for a
really exciting match and uh it's
actually now equal to material and this
is the game between Dennis and Fabian it
seems like Fabiano though has the better
pieces it's nice to have a knight
generally in these positions but maybe
maybe the black king is just a little
bit weak uh here hard to assess
very difficult to assess on the right
hand side a lot easier to assess because
David paravian he's in the driver's seat
against Dimitri on Dragon until I just
opened my mouth because that bar is not
a seesaw it's on a journey up and down
up and down doing some heavy lifting but
I think that now Peruvian has it under
control and Fabiano is he was apparently
winning but he's pre-moving he has no
time
yeah and again this oh this is the
problem that Fabiano had yesterday well
actually did he win he won on time there
right well no he lost on time I'm just
trying to work out
how that went no he lost on time my
mistake
no you're okay he lost that one on time
they were gonna flip the cameras right
now see our team working hard behind the
scenes but for Fabiano he needs to be
quicker in the scrambles but I think one
of his biggest problems and maybe this
is lack of experience in both is that
he's not great at predicting his
opponent's moves I feel like just there
he allowed Dennis to throw that pawn
forward E6 E7 and that's what the best
of the best are able to do we see
nerdinski we see Tang of course farouza
Carlson Nakamura they do this in their
sleep but these players they're able to
accurately predict when their opponents
will pre-move and what they are going to
do in the time scramble so it's really
cool stuff to see it's very hard to be
an expert at but Fabiano he needs to
take a couple games so he can feel a
little bit more confident
yeah that's an interesting thing you
bring up I mean like just the idea that
you're you're ready to remove and you
know exactly what to do it is so
important and you can see here that
Fabiano is in trouble in this second
game as well I mean uh it's it's not
going great here he's a pawn down he has
just won a pawn back though with a nice
tactic and the Queen's now coming off it
still seems preferable for black because
White's pawns are uh quite weak on the
queen side there the white pawns are on
dark squares and they're dark Square
Bishops are on the board so only black
can attack those pawns there so I I
certainly rather be black in this
position
you were spot on in what you were saying
and then fabina agreed with you too much
because he gave up a pawn it was in a
dark Square it was undefended when he
pushed the spawn on G4 and suddenly
Dennis has allowed a drawn end game from
a winning position and now fabi's King
is going to chase down this Pawn but
these are the end games that are drawn
at least according to the engine and
then you mess them up because you only
have 10 seconds
yes and this is where the clock comes in
so so important at this uh Junction of
the game but okay uh they're both uh got
enough time there to get the draw so
Fabiano is Off the Mark he has half a
point already and um straight into the
next game which are moving very quickly
with yeah they are playing a similar
position as they did in the first one uh
it's interesting to see them have such a
combative type of opening where we see
the queen side opening up the king
side's locked down but they're you know
they're going to be some tactics in
these positions and we see now a lot of
trades on the B file I think black is a
nice position but most importantly he's
keeping level on the time
yeah I agree with you it seems like
black is making more progress on the
queen side here uh the B Pawn uh could
be a bit of a weakness uh they are
moving so quick though I mean you talk
about commentators having a hard day at
the office it's a hard day when you're
commentating on bullet chess but look at
the black king there Fabiano's King seem
to be getting into the position and uh
White just trying to keep a fortress and
now that Black Knight has a lovely
Square it can come into on F4 so even
though the evaluation bosses it's even I
much prefer Fabiano's position and good
chance to level the score and in the
other match the score is level
um Dimitri versus David it's I think two
points all so so far very close matches
yeah and Fabiano needs this one because
he would like to have an even sword just
as you mentioned uh do andrekin and
paravian they're playing some
complicated Sicilians on that board oh
the evaluation I saw the bar was up and
then it went down look at that spot by
Unbreaking on the right side he took
upon and C4 distracting that light score
Bishop because it needs to defend the
Knight so on Dragon steals upon gets
away with it Fabi on the left hand side
he's getting down into that treacherous
territory where he's dropping near 10
seconds he dropped his past a pawn but
look at that tactic he just won a piece
beautiful time and he should have enough
time to put this in to the back of the
net he's got a knight and two extra
pawns quite interesting to keep an eye
on this because uh you know we can see
if he's got the speed he's gonna need to
have the speed in this match it's one
thing having the winning position but
you've got to have that skill and it
he's up to the challenge at the moment
that pawn very close
is coming through he did great that this
was actually Exquisite and a bullet game
technique there he 3.7 seconds to
opponent zero because he was pre-moving
giving a check here and there and he was
keeping his pieces close together that's
really important because if you're
pre-moving and your opponent just puts
their Rook where your Rook can take it
but they're of course threatening you
you need to make sure those pieces are
defended so that was really well done
from Fabi he's saying I am up to the
task don't worry guys don't worry about
me I can handle myself but pravin he's
handling himself he just delivered a win
it seems uh against on draken and so he
takes the lead
he does yeah so he edges ahead and it'd
be interesting to see if Dimitri can now
come back and level the score uh this is
the way that match has been going so far
it's been seesawaring up and down like
the evaluation bar I've never seen a
chess competition with grand Masters
where the evaluation bar is so undecided
as it is in bullet chess in bullet
Chelsea evaluation bar just has no idea
where it is is it up is it down it
changes so often
I think it's clear here no no I think
it's very clear you're 100 right then it
goes up and down but right now it's just
going down and not in fabi's favor
because he's down a couple pawns and
those pawns are passed in the center of
the board
yeah very strong pawns and uh okay white
has some kind of blockade but it's still
at least
two extra pawns here and if the black
Rook can get in and just dislodge
White's King which is doing now uh
Fabiano
also down 15 seconds can probably just
resign here meaning that Dennis goes
ahead
and uh Dimitri in his game uh just to
give you an update there
um has a chance to level the score but
we're straight back in and Fabian is
playing the kings in defense a lot
Robert I mean that's is that it's not
normally what he does but he's obviously
done a bit of preparation for this game
yeah so I mean Fabiano going to the
king's Indian I think he has used that
before even at the highest levels of
classical chess but it's probably just
uh trying to get positions trying to
outplay his opponent hasn't worked very
well thus far look at this game I think
that with the bishop pair the open board
that luzvick is doing great stuff and uh
I mean this game here white has all the
control of the board
yeah it's funny because often in the
king's Indian defense a lot of the
pressure happens on the king side and
but so far in all the games everything's
happening with the queen side and in the
last time the last one of these Fabiano
got a very good position as black on the
queen side but in this one it's white
who's dominating
say that and it's a little bit unclear I
mean White's Rook will penetrate into
the position but black also has his Rook
very active and uh
it looks like even black could be better
now all of a sudden Roberts things turn
around in a Flash and father could have
traded queens and won the B4 Pawn a
moment ago but he's going after the
white king and we say this often that in
bullet chess probably the most important
thing besides keeping some time in your
clock is King safety and watch out here
it comes there's threats all over the
board Queen h1's made
that was a lovely game I I mean I love
the way he used his Queen there at the
end a lot of people would have just
swapped Queens taking the pawn but his
Queen just weaved in didn't it like a
like a bit of a Wrigley worm there into
Dennis's position and uh that has
leveled the score there as well these
are gonna be so close uh these matches
already we can feel the tension
yeah so wow what matches we get to start
the day with but it looks like Fabi is
playing badly with white like he just
won a game with black and then as soon
as he gets the white pieces he's in
troubles not the first time we've seen
that today but on the right hand side of
her screen we see paravian with a one
point lead against andrekin that game is
messy if I saw that in classical chess I
wouldn't know how to evaluate it Simon
because we see it's an exchange up for
white but look at all these Pawns in the
center and the fact that White's King
looks a bit vulnerable
totally agree damn with the last move
black is getting ready to sacrifice the
bishop in front of White's King and that
would uh actually Force some really
horrible problems of white but it might
be a draw now oh no the black queen
doesn't have a good square and really in
this position if white can get the
off-white is winning but that's not
going to be easy and white decides he
has to give a piece back but look at
that move the queen does dive in is it
enough to win though
I think there might be oh no the queen
takes D4 is it checked oh he just allows
it I was about to say need to be very
careful with the black king escaping all
the checks Rook D3 that cannot get the
job done
and he just goes on the check and that's
the wrong movement White's gonna win
oh all of a sudden the hunter becomes
the hunted and that black king is now in
a horrible situation
and I think
there was something even stronger than
this but this is very very
a very sensible way of doing it white
Queens first that was a very painful
loss there for Dimitri and that's what
we call class right the fact that you
don't just go for a Checkmate but you
recognize in a split second that you can
trade off all the pieces and win the
king and pawn end game that was really
nicely done it is unfortunate for
Dimitri on draken but I have to kind of
give a shout out to David paravin for
spotting that instantly
yeah a very good play from uh David
there um he's proving his Blitz
abilities taking a two-point lead as
well and um Dimitri is quite well known
for his kind of rather obscure openings
at the level he's at I mean normally
when you're at the 27 sort of 50 level
you're playing main lines but that's not
the way Dimitri plays and this should
give him advantages in the opening but
David is also an opening expert as well
so it's very interesting to see how
they're they're struggling in the
opening White's position here though
looks fantastic to me Robert he's the
exchange up and a pawn up as well to
boot yeah I mean this is just he's
mowing him down he's just like give me
all your pieces and he forced
resignation that was as efficient of a
win as you can get in bullet and there's
still 17 minutes on the match clock so
plenty of time for someone who's
trailing and let's not forget we should
remind everybody that it's win by two
and that was very important yesterday in
the matchup between Anish and Jose
Martinez Anish had a lead even in extra
time but he couldn't separate by two
points Jose was able to come back and
then win the sudden death game yes uh
that is an important thing I mean I
think the last one of the last times I
was commentating chess.com it was years
ago but this is a new rule so this is
something that uh we'll have to get used
to and uh going to the position now
white is building up his pieces very
nicely around Black's King and there's a
big threat here that rook and the queen
can now come in can't it Queen takes
pawn and it has taken that pawn using
the pin black has to resign there's no
good way to stop Checkmate in front of
the black king on the next move
yeah no that was a very it shouldn't win
I mean I said it before that's another
efficient win and so we see this one
still continue to provide entertainment
and I just want to give a shout out to
some other bullet chess champion
participants because Hikaru Nakamura
alireza faruja Magnus Carlsen are all
playing at title Tuesday so they're
playing in title Tuesday they're gonna
finish that and then hop into the BCC
and Hikaru starts six out of six
ferrugia is six out of seven he finishes
seventh round uh Magnus was five and a
half out of six last eye check so
they're also the top of the standings
there they can't be stopped
I'm actually playing title Tuesday at
the moment as well
just in case you were wondering uh what
I'm doing occasionally look over there
and uh I think I'm on seven out of six
as well
you're wondering how my tournament's
going uh no I'm certainly not it's hard
enough playing bullet chess that's a lot
of chess for the guys as well isn't it
that's a hell of a lot of Chess it
really is and I just want to also note
that five and a Corona just flagged
Dennis lazovic I watched it happen off
to the side that he was uh he Flags upon
he gave away material didn't matter
because he had extra time so that is
well done by Fabi who has taken the lead
in their match and here we see that on
draken is in trouble a pravian that was
the person I predicted to win this match
he's looking like he's well on his way
but they're still almost 15 minutes
remaining
your predictions are pretty good Robert
I mean at the moment it does seem like
uh bravian has the upper hand in that
match he seems to be quicker uh you look
at the time there he's got a big time
advantage and he's spotting tactics uh
very very well and uh those are the two
two main things that make you a bullet
Champion so
um I think Dimitri is going to have to
change things up I mean one good bit of
advice I give if you're you know in the
match it's not going your way just
change your openings and at this level
the players have so many different
openings uh available to them they can
certainly mix it up and I think he needs
to try something right Robert at the
moment uh because he's getting in a bit
of trouble and he's going to be now
three points behind yeah not good for
andragon he's somebody who does sort of
stick to his typical repertoire and oh
my goodness look at five's Bishop on
each one this reminds me of that 960
game where Peter stidler was playing
against Wesley so he never got his
Bishop out of the corner that is a very
terrible piece on H1
wow I I I'm sure Fabby just wants to get
rid of that position and he does because
that was one of the worst Bishops I've
ever seen it was it was horrendous and
um Abby now on Four Points the same as
Dennis so it really close match there as
well and he's sticking to the king's
Indian defense so he's he's giving this
a go and he's gonna get his Knight into
that middle Square first but maybe
White's doing okay here yeah it's a Nate
that can block here to pass Pawn Knights
can see over it's the Knight on D3 is
staring at the pawn E5 but Black's
progress is happening too quickly queen
of Rook lined up on an open file we saw
Fabi deliver a Checkmate a few games ago
in a similar way uh but he did give away
a Pawn on the king side and then Dennis
gave right back
yeah and it's a similar Queen to oh here
it comes look at that queen that was a
beautiful switch around and his
Checkmate on the boards yeah that was
sick but that in your pipe and smoke it
young Dennis
oh my goodness that happened in a Flash
that is great full board awareness
that's something that I know I struggle
with in speed chess is you know I get
concentrated I get tunneled on an area
of the board but Bobby was hunting the
king and he quickly recognized the G6
score was vacated once he took that
Pawnee Drive
yeah that's very good the switch around
to the other side of the board not easy
to see that sometimes especially in
bullet chess and I think actually at
lower levels one of the things I I
notice that lower rated players often
don't see is that awareness of the whole
board they focus on one area of the
board they don't look enough on the
other side and uh you will see these
players having very good awareness of
all areas of the board I have to say
though you know when Fabi gets a nice
win with black he files it up with kind
of a clunker of a game with white he's
right now down a pawn uh he's I guess
getting it back so something just
happened there but he needs to figure
out his white openings because they have
not been going his way
yeah I I mean 100 agree with you I mean
yesterday it says black openings he was
struggling against the Jabara London
system no surprise there a brilliant
opening uh but you were here a little
bit biased but you would have thought
that someone is well prepared as Fabiano
because he's played World Championship
matches right would have a great opening
repertoire and not be getting in trouble
especially with the white pieces so um
it's bizarre that he's getting bad
positions with uh the white pieces and I
see that uh naroditsky Daniel in the
chat is also agreeing the jibava London
system hello Daniel is a fantastic
opening and Anya has done a very good
course on it if you want to uh if you
want to learn more about it as well yeah
no you and Daniel both have created a
great instructional material for so many
people to learn about London but this
you don't really need to learn much when
that King is trapped in the corner
there's a boundary there so unlike other
past pawns when when you have a rook
Pawn you cannot win the game in fact
Bobby might lose this if he's not
careful on time but he's the head in the
clock he's trying to flag Dennis
they did this before right I mean I I
like this so uh Robert show the younger
player you know flagging younger players
oh he didn't manage it but you know it's
a nice idea something that I can never
do myself but worth a try and the reason
why it is hard to flag song from that
position is your king can't move so
you're much more likely to have a
three-time repetition Dania would not
have pushed the a pawn so fast he would
have waited spent some moves trying to
flag his opponent then pushed the king
to A8 and pawn A7 you need to avoid
three-time repetitions in that type of
position it's hard to do I know I'm just
sitting in my chair I'm not even
criticizing I'm just trying to note that
it's what I see from done he bit a long
match against Min last night and he was
able to get the job done and win that
match I think they put like 50 games so
Simon we're back in the sort of Kings
Indian structure once again I like
White's position I think that pawns are
dropping and F7 is probably an important
one
yeah I mean the the black king now uh
quite exposed there as well uh in the
position and look at this there's a big
threat on the ball Bishop F6 that Bishop
is threatening just to come in and check
mate Black's King and I'm not sure if
Fabiana has any defense against this and
that's the case it'll be five and a half
all which is just yo-yoing about okay
he's trying a bit desperately to get out
of this maybe the best chance but uh the
H Pawn can now come in and do the job uh
if the Queen's ever come off it's a very
easy win for white as well so good
fighting here but I don't think it's
going to be enough well I say that
important Pawn is just one
the H Pawn comes through the age Pawn oh
I was about to say that he didn't have
enough time but this suddenly is a draw
by repetition
wow
look at this wrong Square though
apparently oh dear
oh
again the evaluation bar it just goes
crazy there was a chance there uh but in
the final position White had checked
mate with G6 so it's all even this is a
really really close match to update you
very quickly in the other match
um it looks like David has a four point
lead over Dimitri so this is probably
the match to stay on I think Robert as
it's so so close yeah it is and you know
as you mentioned that I just saw that uh
the player is upset because they uh
let's say David Mr win in an end game
but that match continues it does seem
like David has this one uh in the bag so
he'll move on in the lose right
congratulations uh maybe it's a little
too soon I don't want to jinx him but it
does seem like they're private isn't
charging once again Fabiano has a
terrible position with white I I can't
believe I'm saying this because he is
one of the best prepared players on the
planet but somehow every game he's had
with the white pieces it feels like he's
misplitted horribly
his opponent should certainly take note
here of what what what's going wrong
right because uh as you say whenever you
well what's happened here okay Black's
getting the piece back so it's okay but
I I never see Fabiano in the problems in
the opening that he's actually getting
today in yesterday it is this kind of
recurring theme
now the black queen comes in I love this
maneuver look at that the black queen
just sneaking all the way around and a
rook trying to join in the attack here
this is really really good play from
Dennis white defending excellently as
well so far though yeah really nicely
done by both players Dennis still with
the advantage uh but that Knight comes
into D5 the King goes to h8 avoiding any
sort of checks with discoveries so I
think both players I mean they have to
move fast to this juncture and they're
kind of just moving randomly that's what
it feels like
oh yeah and well that's a big move
winning the queen there and uh also the
Knight so the only chance here is to win
on time
blockade is not happening here black has
too many pawns on the king side and um
that Rook is very loose as well
there goes a pawn important porn I have
to say some pretty decent previews from
both sides that's important to note
because it's a win by two match so even
if one player has a lead you need to
have a two-point lead to win the match
but I think Dennis he's playing this
excellently the clocks actually are
getting close to even but it's a winning
King and pawn and game for Dennis
lazwick he's taking this
he is that was actually very very good
play from Dennis even at the end there
when you're the queen up if you're not
moving quickly you could even lose that
kind of position which I've done many
times before hence why when I'm playing
bullet chess I'm only throwing my
computer out the window and
I swear to never play again it's it's so
it's so hard did you like playing bullet
yourself Robert no no no I'm not a
bullet player it's too much for me my
wrist just starts killing me as soon as
I play a few games and it's at some
point you just have to stop thinking
about Chess and that's the hard part is
I'm just playing a game with my mouse
versus playing a game of chess but uh
these two matches have been a lot of fun
thus far it looks like on draken he has
cut into the lead a bit but as soon as
we tune into his match it seems like
he's a bad position against pravin
yeah and I think that's a problem a lot
of chess players have their their wrists
getting very aching and um in the match
here yeah it's it's looking
I don't know there's still a chance with
Dimitri right instead of chart well I
don't know five minutes
he's got to win this one it's not gonna
happen is it yeah he needs to win two
games they cut it to a one point
match but yeah this game can't really
see how he wins this unless he somehow
wins on time
only chance there but it's still going
to be after that two points and four in
a bit minutes so he's not gonna do it it
looks like David is gonna be going
through and
um
playing so well today your predictions
are spot on do you have a match much
closer Dennis now in the lead by one
point there
and it looks like it could be going two
points up so Fabiano also in trouble in
that match yeah probably should just
resign this one get a couple games in
and give himself a chance but his
openings which are usually his calling
card have been anything but that
I'm looking at you know that matchup
two-point lead for lazwick and it looks
like paravian he has been in charge of
this match but Dragon still has
technically enough time to strike if he
wins this game and then gets another win
then he still remains in the match
yeah he needs to win quickly here and
get another game under his belt I mean
it looks very unlikely uh his position
is also a bit dubious uh the the match
though that could be going down to the
wire is aviano's match and it's cleared
Fabiano must at least get a result here
maybe a win I kind of feel that he needs
to win this game with the white pieces I
like his position he's got control of
the open file very surprised that G5 was
played there but this is Black's idea
trying to liberate his dark Square
bishop and Fabiano now grabbing some
pawns but it oh dear look at that Robert
he's blunders right he has to resign but
that was a really well played start to
the game and then just completely
unaware that his opponent was going to
give him a check and win a rook on D1 so
um Fabi I thought like a superb opening
a change of pace from the earlier games
but yeah that was not a finish it was a
a bit Reckless you could say by just
taking all the queen side Pawns
yeah 100 agree and it's having that
sense of danger which is so important in
all kinds of churches it's a lot harder
to get that sense of danger in bullet
chess uh but when you I mean one thing
I've noticed is that Dennis is doing
excellently is weaving his Queen into
the position so you know he's using that
Queen so well yeah and right now for it
Dennis over here he is stolen an H Pawn
in front of the black king uh the
position remains a bit locked up and
Bobby says locked up no more let's go
Knight takes B3 maybe a viable tactic at
some point instead plays A4 but I oh the
Evo Bar says it's five zero that Bishop
23 is loose great tactical awareness
from Fabi
what Dennis should do now is not resign
but like draw down the clock I mean he
is three points ahead so just trying to
play some moves that will annoy Fabiano
and there's only two minutes left so in
actual fact if he doesn't even move he
will win this match now that's a bit of
a shock I expected Fabiano to go through
but this young Dennis he's proven to be
he's proven to be quite some player
right I mean he's uh he's very good at
the quicker time limits for sure
Dennis the Menace but Fabi if he wins
this he does get another game and if he
wins that he cuts it to one so Simon
there is a chance I am saying there's a
chance especially now that Bobby just
picked up the queen and is winning this
game
yeah
is it one point or was it two we get an
update on that soon it might might only
might only be it might not be enough
time and I love that nickname Dennis the
Menace uh I mean that that's I mean I
bet a lot of people watching this don't
even know what Dennis the Menace is
anymore
when you're my age you're well aware
what Dennis the Menace was great cartoon
character
and by the way Dennis taking your advice
not resigning not making that final move
but the game it's going to take off so
one minute remains which means that this
last game will count and it might not
actually be the last game if Fabiano can
win it so it's win or you're out for
Fabi he is the white pieces he needs to
play much better than he has when he's
had the first move advantage
do you know what I forgot Robert I
forgot you need a two-point lead this is
my mistake so
um well well spotted there Robert
actually if Fabiano wins it's only going
to be a one point lead and that would
mean that Dennis has to win the next one
of course to get it so this is as you
say a chance it's a chance for Fabiana
the match is not over but Fabiano must
win it's the oh what's he done there he
hasn't walked into a four Cassie what
what was that what was that by Dennis
you just gave us cool
I think it was a mouth slip I think he
Mouse slipped oh a pretty good position
oh my goodness and now he's getting
checkmated
wow what a what a stroke of luck that
was
uh unbelievable and there's only gonna
be a one point in it now
so it would that must have been a mouse
slip there I think Robert the only thing
that could explain it it definitely was
a mouse of it the question I have now
that Dennis resigned did he resign after
the match clock hit zero or before
because if the matchup didn't hit zero a
draw would still keep the match going I
guess it still does anyway it doesn't
really matter but it changes when the
sixth game of extra time begins so that
was absolutely bizarre I think Dennis
was deserving to have the lead does
match he did uh manage himself better
than Fabiano just getting an advantage
throughout the openings and converting
them but Simon you we know how it is in
chess psychology how the match is going
trajectory is it probably doesn't feel
very good for him right now
no I mean maybe even feels a bit worse
because they've got a break right I mean
when you lose a game like that uh you
might just want to get back into it and
be like bang I need to play but okay the
match situation is very very intense
here and um let's just remind everyone
Dennis needs to get a two-point lead so
if he wins this game he goes through the
Fabiano who can draw or win he stays in
the competition this is really exciting
stuff and I love what Fabiano is doing
here getting lots of play on The Queen
side Robert yeah congratulations to
David perriving it was sort of a
foregone conclusion so we didn't
remember to congratulate him on his
match Victory but well done against his
compatriot Dimitri on draken and in this
game as you said it looks good for black
it's kind of like a Banco Gambit where
you haven't sacrificed a pawn
yeah that's right I mean uh the benko
Gambit is a very Dynamic opening to play
but as you mentioned Robert black still
has that a pawn here okay we can see
Dennis pushing on the king side this is
a risky strategy because you're also
opening up your own King so whose King
is going to be weaker is it the white
king or the black king that's what this
game is gonna go down to I think and
what's this an exchange sacrifice he
wanted Bishop E6 Rook H1 meat but I
think he might have forgot that the
bishop could take on D4 freeing the G7
Square for the black king and suddenly
we see it is the white king in danger
with that Rook coming to h8 but that
move F5 it could be scary for black
absolute mess on the board here both
kings are in real problems here F6 looks
very tempting this move threatening
Queen takes G6 but black gets the rook
in first and now black seems to be very
safe and also Fabiano has been using his
Queen brilliantly to infiltrate into the
position here comes that Queen again
oh but Fabiano cannot lose this game and
I'm looking at the clock he can't lose
he can drop it draws okay but why draw
when you're picking up a rook
oh he's got to win this he's got 11
seconds but he's completely winning we
have Checkmate on the board
whoa Dennis has got to be feeling rather
depressed now it's eight and a half all
oh my goodness this is where tilt cannot
happen not at this stage and Dennis he's
doing his best here with the black
pieces you see the Evo bar saying that
black is better so Dennis is showing his
might his great preparation from the
black side he's such a sturdy player so
we'll see if he can write the ship right
now
yeah definitely uh it means I think more
he's got a bounce back psychologically
from two losses in a row
um and that has just happened so White's
position okay I mean I still quite light
white no matter what the evaluation Bar
says but Black's also got his Knight to
a fantastic Square probably about even
at this moment in time
and that pawn pushed H5 was to stop
black from playing G5 the bishop 104
doesn't have many squares but this open
file for the white Rook that's the most
valuable one Black's Rooks they're
staring into pawns and pieces that work
on A6 hitting A7 and E6
I mean I think I'm gonna you know I was
wondering whether I should say this but
this is why biano is such a star uh
because how he deals with pressure right
I mean he's dealt with the highest
levels of pressure he's got that extra
experience and he seems to be
taking over the match now if he wins
this game it's going to be the end and
look at that pawn dropping the light
squares look so weak there goes another
Pawn but black does have this B Pawn to
stir up some tricks yeah but H6 the
black king is just in too much danger
and this is over I mean the black king
is just getting mated it would seem so
Fabiano is going to take what his fourth
game in a row I feel for Dennis lazovic
it's no fun to be in a match where you
feel like you have it almost in the bag
and suddenly five reached into his bag
of tricks and takes four in a row and he
is the lead for the maybe the first time
all match
yep he has the lead and he just needs to
win this game with the black pieces so
what a comeback from Fabiano this has
been very inspiring and uh he's going
for the same setup where most of the
action will happen on the queen side and
they both have a lot of experience in
this position if black can generate that
play okay but he's switching to the king
side here I kind of like this idea some
of those dark squares on the king side
look quite nice and black if black can
get his pieces into them but look at
this queen F2 Queen takes H4 it's not
quite in time so he goes for the pawn in
this manner and yeah do you care about
that part it's compensation very clearly
in the dark squares for black
definitely look at Black's dark squared
Bishop uh this looks like fantastic
compensation black I mean no matter what
the evaluation Bar says it's King safety
which is often the most important thing
but that is two pawns is it two pawns
too many maybe especially now the light
squares are about to be harped into that
night on D4 going right into F5 oh the
black king on H7 not exactly the
happiest piece and D6 was hanging so he
tried to trade Queens but then G5 false
no this is going to be Lazarus game and
this would be a very nice bounce back
for him
yeah he needs it he needs to win this
game and uh are we going to see a sudden
death I always lose track of what the
sudden death point is it goes so quickly
but uh we we will get an update on that
because obviously they can't just keep
going to and throwing
um at the moment
there's not really anything between them
yes the fourth game now uh of six so uh
there is no separation between these two
nine and a half nine and a half and they
can afford to lose if you can remember
in the back of your head that it's win
by two and that actually takes a bit of
pressure off this individual game but
once again Fabi has a bad position with
the white pieces I don't think I've ever
seen this from him
I have no idea what's going on with it
with his openings I mean just just
switch them up look at White's King
White's King is so weak your Pawn on G4
shouldn't be there it gives a little bit
of air around your king you expose your
king never good to expose yourself just
remember that people you want to keep
your clothes on when you're in public
and that white king it's just too naked
I feel and somehow he's surviving so
it's been a good defensive effort thus
far from him but if he gets his Bishop
trapped on E3 that also will be game
over even if it's not checkmate
Black's certainly still pushing here I
think Robert I mean why as you say is
doing a great job defending but that is
an important Pawn uh that black has
picked up here now black just trying to
go into the ending
white is a pawn down but with really bad
coordination with his piece as well look
at the Black Knight right in the middle
of the board dominating uh the the board
there and the piece we haven't spoken
about is the 17th piece the clock and
it's all up in Dennis lazovic's favor
Fabi is losing on the board he's losing
on time so unless Dennis blunders and we
have seen him lose his Queen in an
unfortunate way in that final game of
regular time this is Dennis's game and
it's clear right now that he is going to
win
yeah and
yeah there's nothing that could be done
here that that pawn on E3 in front of
White's King is just too strong the
black king Canal motoring but he's going
for the ending and uh one game away from
winning the match so uh again Fabiano
needs to get a result here
and we'll see if he can perform with the
black pieces because the first move
Advantage has been good for neither side
but they just should they want black
every time if you said one game
Armageddon they're both spending all
their time give me the black pieces
because they have not been getting it
done with white but as soon as I said
that I'm looking at this one uh it's
looking like a mixed bag where white has
this nice Central Bishop on D4 but black
is trying to make use of the queen side
yeah I like Black's Bishop on the queen
side and now the Knight is popping in as
well uh Dennis is just going for it on
the king side and when you swap off that
dark Square Bishop of blacks the black
king is always weak here and practically
speaking that King can get in a lot of
trouble on F5 now the White Queen as a
win this could be it this could be the
end that black king is just so so weak
here uh oh as a make when it's six
where's the Checkmate I don't see it oh
it's the back rank mate and queen takes
E7 that's game that's gonna be match
brilliant play there from Dennis oh
there's nothing that can be done and
Dennis takes it down wow look at all
those medals behind him as well it just
to intimidate his opponents he's lining
up the medals there he's got so many for
a 17 year old but taking down uh Fabiano
is is impressive right really impressive
I think we just saw Dennis breathe for
the first time in about an hour he is
able to escape and move on in the losers
bracket so David paravian and Dennis
lasveg they say I don't care that I'm
playing Super gems I got this and they
did they move on Dimitri on Drake in
Fabiano caruana they get two thousand
dollars for their efforts but we have to
say goodbye to our first two contestants
of the 2023 bullet Chess Championship
yeah we do it's it's always sad to lose
such Legends of the game as uh Dimitri
and uh Fabiano there and uh that that
match with Fabiana was so so close it
looked like he was going to do it uh
Robert he came right back into the match
but they both showed some great resolve
there
for sure and because that match went
into extra time it means we're gonna
take a look at the bracket see in these
players moving on we don't know who
they're going to face because people
dropped down from the Winner's bracket
once they lose so Dennis and David they
get to play again but we don't know who
they're gonna face because well let's
look at the top of this bracket here
there are eight players in the Winner's
side of things and one of them will drop
down to face David bravin or Dennis last
book but as I was saying because we did
just go into extra time it means we're
gonna have to head on over shortly for a
break because when we return there's
much more chess to be had it's bullet
chest it's wild it's fun you will not
want to miss more from the bullet Chess
Championship day two here in 2023.
[Music]
chess kit is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
the kids that feels just like playing
but chess is a great way to learn
patience strategy and critical thinking
chess kid features a comprehensive
training program that guides kids to
level up on their way to Mastery there
are more than 50 000 chest muscles and a
whole library of entertaining videos
that teach strategies tactics openings
and end games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
[Music]
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the Champions chess tour to
the candidates speed chess championship
title Tuesday feed a world championship
and so much more chess.com events has
all of the top chess tournaments played
both over the board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
even compete by voting for your
predicted results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
and we are back here at the bullet Chess
Championship we just said goodbye to two
players Dimitri on draken and five in a
carwana but we say hello to two more
matches Simon these games these matches
have been so entertaining we just got
more extra time what do you expect to
see coming up
um more excitement uh it's been quick
it's been fast and uh the other thing
we're seeing is the matches are a lot
closer now that last one Fabiano just
going out in the tie break scenario and
uh our next match is well you know
um
they they're still in the losers bracket
let's remind everyone that so it's the
last chance to lure for the players if
any of these players lose the match they
do go home you get the double Chance in
This tournament so it's double pressure
and any feelings about this match
Roberts
well I think we have to talk about the
elephant in the room something that
maybe our viewers don't know about when
we're talking about the upcoming matches
Eric Henson is taking on Arjun aragaisi
and Arjun era geisi I'm looking at it on
my phone he's playing in Beale in a
classical game against yugangi trying to
defend a worst position so as we look at
our next two matchups we may in fact
only have one because one of these
matches may be decided by forfeit
right and that does mean at least we can
concentrate on a niche's match and it's
also pretty good news for Eric and I
know Eric would love to win his match by
uh playing but still if you get through
to the next round you get a little bit
more money in the pocket what a bad
thing is it for him and he can have
another cocktail as well yeah I think
those characters were free we you know
we heard his brother making them so
regardless uh Eric Hansen unless
something changes in origin era guys
he's over the board game it will be Eric
going through but somebody who needs to
prove that they are capable of making it
through is Anish giri he is the star
from the Netherlands he won Tata steel
masters section earlier this year that
was a huge deal for him five-time Dutch
Champion he defeated Jordan Von forest
in tybrick again this year and he is
appearing in his first bullet Chess
Championship so we've seen his successes
in many different time patrols but this
is his first foray into the treacherous
jungle that is the BCC
yeah I mean it was really close if you
if you're watching yesterday everyone
out there you can maybe just recall his
match that he had against Jose and that
went down again to the wire and Jose is
a you know very well known bullet player
and a niche not so much but we did see
lots of positive things from a niche in
that match uh he was getting good
positions he was actually playing
incredibly quickly as well at the right
moments and I mean that must surely make
him favorite there I mean he's a higher
rated chess player and he was pretty
quick right Robert
yeah he was very fast and somebody who
did not have his best day yesterday but
it's hard to have your best day when
you're playing against Nakamura was Amin
Ohan Young And The Armenian
International Master he's working
towards that GM title he's very close I
expect in a couple months he will have
it but he did really lose a tough
matchup and I say tough not because it
was close and he can be heartbroken
about but just because you're playing
Hikaru and if you lose 22 and a half to
one and a half like he did that's gonna
happen to most players in the world so
Anish he doesn't really come into this
match knowing what to expect I'd imagine
because yeah his opponent lost to akaru
and that's just par for the course
yeah I agree I mean Hikaru can make
everyone look like an idiot when he
plays them he's just so so remarkably
strong
um both players now getting ready we can
see them on the camera and um I I
thought yesterday that uh
um you know there was some resemblance
between Eric Hansen uh and I mean I I
don't know does anyone else see that or
is that just that just me saying that
I'm not sure do you see that Robert do
you reckon I mean has a little bit of
Eric Hansen about him or am I just
imagining that and maybe with his style
you know Anish has played for the chess
bras maybe in the future I mean will be
a chess bra because uh his shirt I like
it I think uh you know he's right a good
one today but he really has his work cut
out for him because Anish giri is a
super great master and oftentimes super
gyms aren't that great at bullet chess
because they're not playing it Anish is
different he's built different and he is
really strong at bullet as we saw
yesterday
he is he's incredibly good at bullets
and he's got to be the big favorite but
you never know uh I mean playing okay
and it's the match has started and we're
seeing a dragon
dangerous opening from a niche yeah I'm
a bit surprised that he's going for
these kind of hostile lines but you see
by how quickly he's playing he's well
prepared he's not afraid and I did
message with the niche full disclosure
he and I talked yesterday he was
disappointed by his loss he felt like he
could have won that match towards the
end there was some night end game where
he was up a couple pawns and he felt
like he really let that match go so he
is not just a person who's saying oh I'm
gonna come to the bull Chess
Championship and I'll play a couple
matches and if I bow out that's okay he
wants to win his matches and well he's
not off to the best start here Ohanian
has a good position with white
yes
um I mean the dragon is a very risky
opening to play and why not seem to be
doing pretty well here with that lovely
open file and um some I'd say better
Pawn structure here a niche pushing on
the king side though making a bit of
progress there and I'm surprised the
evaluation bar was so high in White's
favor and it's actually now dropped to
say it's pretty even position
and so in the Black Knight I mean it's
working its way maneuvering oh he went
backwards I thought he wanted to go
forwards but his King was in the e-file
and the pawn was pinned but he's just
blundered he just blundered uh just a
big big blunder there and now white has
a completely winning position
um you've still got to make the
Breakthrough though not so simple to do
and this is a good idea when you've got
extra material make exchanges a niche
trying to complicate the matter
wait did he just want to be winning this
did he have politics E4 and Rook D5
Checkmate like that was very close with
that King on C5 but speaking of
Checkmate that King on Asics has no
moves so if you can somehow
what a draw
you won't see many drawers like this
look at Ohana he's like he can't believe
it he's beside himself as the first game
of the match he had the upper hand but
that was good recognition by Anish he
spotted the king of No Escape squares
let's just go back and forth
yeah that was that was an exciting first
game to get us started there and um
maybe a bit worrying for a niche fans as
uh his position was the worst he did
manage to recover
and this next game now
seems like black is doing totally okay
out of the opening
yes and doing well on the clock I don't
know where Anish spent 16 plus seconds
but the position looks about neutral uh
for the two sides I'm just going to be
worried about nisha's clock it's like
improve to me that he is going to keep a
steady pace
yeah I think I'd prefer actually to be
black here because black has more space
it's often easier to move when you have
that space Advantage there's a bit of a
weakness in the middle of the board you
see this on the D3 Pawn blacks Rooks are
lined up against that pawn and look at
that black knight the Black Knight has
now landed and captured that pawn so
black goes a pawn up uh White struggling
here and black playing very well but oh
I don't like that decision you're given
white a big past Pawn oh I hated that I
mean normally I don't use the strong
language but that giving weight a
protected pass Pawn on the rim that had
to be a bad decision and I don't know if
a niche can make progress here he might
just go back and forth but black can't
move the knight from D5 upon E3 is loose
The Rook on E8 can't move otherwise that
hunger's up to A6 so it feels like both
sides are oh and he's going for the win
I was gonna say both sides were stuck
yeah interesting decision from an agency
I think he just realizes that his a pawn
is so so strong and black has to really
as he is here remain tied down because
that one little Pawn but you know black
does have this Pawn on E3 as well and I
love what Black's doing I thought he's
going to bring his King over to stop
that pawn he's changed his mind yeah and
oh he gave up his past one was take it
all of white queenside pawns and now
it's a Time scramble look at a niche
he's ahead on the clock he's going to
try to flag ohanya
yeah he's doing everything he can
wow look at the speed they're playing at
King B7 and White's winning
can he do this in time yeah he
definitely has this we saw his mouth
skills yesterday uh for Anish this is
just easy
remarkable it is easy and
wow impressive play from a niche there
um but uh Robert and again I think mean
is going to be kicking himself he had a
great position but a niche playing for
the win in what could have been well
what should have been probably a drawn
position so brave play as well from a
niche and you imagine Brave play I like
the openings that we're getting this
isn't some kind of static positional
battle uh we are seeing some serious
tactical fireworks and we're getting
another Sicilian the black kings on h8
staying off that A2 G8 diagonal from the
light score Bishop but as I look at this
position I'm waiting I was obviously
waiting for the strike and there it is
whoa
woof a lovely counter I did from an each
threatening Checkmate on G2 I see that
uh we we have someone in the chat um
saying I can't follow this guys can you
ask him to slow down please
I do feel the same myself quite often
um it'd be good I think chesscott.com
need to make a a slow motion button uh
Robert for these events you can just
press it and everything's in slow motion
for like old people like me you know
more leisurely Pace yeah no I think that
to actually analyze the chest that would
be good for everybody including the
players and that's why the speeches
Championship exists whoa oh that was
apparently winning for black and then
went to losing with that
find by you and by ohanyon
bang and the queen is coming into the
position this is the end you can't even
take that Bishop because Knight F6 wins
the White Queen and uh a big win there
for me and he's gonna he's gonna level
the score
yeah one half one half he's as many
points as he did yesterday against
Hikaru and as we said when you play
Hikaru that kind of thing happens Amino
is a fantastic bullet player he
qualified his way into this field and so
we'll see if Anish can bounce back after
that tough third game but with the white
pieces he's going for what I like to
call the super GM slow death right you
go for like the slight Advantage into
the end game and then try to outlast
your opponent
yeah it's probably a good strategy he's
this is the kind of position that a
niche really likes playing
on a risk free and
um you have this Square on the center of
the board I think black is doing okay
here but it's just easier for white to
play his pawns can advance a little bit
quicker than blacks and there you go
he's trying to he has created a weakness
on the left hand side of the board
I don't know if I'd like that decision
Robert of getting rid of that Knight
there you and I both had the same
reaction at the same time Simon I was
like that cannot be good this is classic
case of fantastic that's a stallion on
D4 it's Untouchable not a single black
piece can attack it and that Bishop on
D7 it's staring into all sorts of brick
walls so this is a 96 check there was a
fork there so that's where the Rook
moved but yeah this looks like it's
going to be mop-up Duty for a niche now
yeah as you say Robin says it's still I
think very good for white right it's a
case of that that Bishop it's not a good
piece in this ending take on H5 play F5
play F6 you win the pollen game
oh lovely lovely play
one of the best end game players in the
world a niche now he's got a decision to
make why didn't he take that one I'm not
sure
because of this move wow brilliant play
and it apparently is not winning for a
way it feels like it should be he's
trying to go for he's trying to like uh
kick the king out shoulder it but now
the Kings come back towards the pond so
is Anish he's going for the clock look
at the time and he just needs to keep
his C3 Pawn defended and move his Knight
around a budge oh buddy put his Knight
on the worst Square
[Music]
oh dear you know
and uh yeah that that was uh that that
was a big Miss for a niche and she had a
good chance there to uh to get a lead in
that one he had a brilliant ending and
very good save uh from amine and now
we're seeing a bit more of a maneuvering
game here yes oh then the f file open
there could be pressure against the
black king but I think that's a learning
moment a teaching moment for a niche
where uh he could have won the game by
flagging uh Ohio but he put his Knight
on the rim and they say Knights on the
rim are dim and that was actually a good
example of why it just got trapped over
there so he couldn't just hop around the
board but in this game this looks pretty
good for white if I didn't have the eval
bar for the side but it says black is
better
evaluation bar does trick me as well I
was thinking exactly the same I was
thinking the black king is weak here you
you have a great chance to attack it any
well the evaluation bar is catching up
with us Robert well we were right all
along there of course you yes of course
and H6 is hanging but for some reason it
may allow the e-pawn to go forward as it
does Knight F5 at some moment so it does
seem like black is holding everything
together but I'm with you it just felt
like okay now it is winning for white
little trick though if you take the
Knight there's a queen check oh you're
going for it because of this move that
was really well calculated and now the
black king
surely in a Checkmate net here but where
is The Knockout maybe King H1 now that
your Rook on F1 is defended play King
each one but he's not finding it and I
think he might stumble into repetition
if he's not careful wow but he's going
for the ending I mean this is this is a
a backup thing that he has with the
extra material
and he's just keeping it very simple
here
so can you oh you see the Eva bar go
down because he can't trade the Queens
like he wanted to yeah
Wayne endings are notoriously tough
because there's so many checks that are
just impossible to calculate and as
white here you can fall into Perpetual I
like what White's doing but
very nearly a Perpetual check it's just
on the clock just on the clock but he
and he put his Queen he gave a check but
he walked into a counter check and now
it's clear it's a win for Ohanian so I
mean he is a determined player right now
he was not happy with his performance
yesterday and he's saying I already have
more points today double that I did
yesterday
playing great chess today as well I
really like what he's doing he's not
only playing tactics as a mix of
positional play and um into this game
well a niche has got to keep the score
close
interesting what Anish has done those
white Pawns in the middle they are they
strong or are they weak they're double
pawns but they do cover a lot of squares
and sometimes having double Pawns in the
middle of the board is a good thing
because here for example you stop the
Black Knights from jumping into the
position
yeah the Knight on E6 and G6 where are
they going exactly the answer is nowhere
anytime soon and the D6 Pawn now is a
bit tender but look at those Rooks for
black they are putting pressure on the
white king side and white barely in time
to defend
yeah
and will we have a mass exchange here
nope the Black Knight Dives in
Queen and Knight notoriously tricky
white has a bit more space here but
black has the better structure it's much
better structure but I get oh and E4
looks very tender Queen G6 I thought was
going to be the way
good spot there Robert I think I would
have won a pawn quite nicely and he can
play it now as well it was another
chance to get the black queen to wear
them
with the fork
and he tried it again but it's not quite
as strong now and now the white king is
perfectly placed I like the King on D3
because then you can get your knight
back you protect the C4 Pawn
yeah Niche now defending very well here
B5 he gets it gets a great Square for
his Knight this could actually turn
and don't wait don't play Queen before I
was gonna say because the queen takes F6
check they're all sorts of knife Forks
but this is clearly turning for white
yeah draw quite lightly but again it
comes down to the clock here
should be a draw they just have to keep
each other's Kings out of the position
but black is very short of time is that
a draw I think that was a draw but
that's not a close game Robert that's a
mistake Simon he could have flagged him
lose all your pieces except for one Pawn
as long as you win on time you get a
full point I think a niche he needs to
be more Shameless he needs to stop
thinking oh you know what's the best
move and just go for the flag because he
had the position where amid had a force
opposition that takes some time just
bring your king back a couple times and
then see what happens so I think that he
wasted an opportunity
Robert I'm I'm always a little bit I
feel a little bit dirty after flagging
my opponents like that you know I kind
of feel like oh I don't know if I should
have done that but it is a legitimate
part of the game right you have to flag
him in the dirtiest manner possible is
that what I've got to do I've got to
start being a bit more a bit more
cold-hearted right I think so and I
actually see Daniel talk about this on
stream quite a bunch where people like
why didn't you accept that person's draw
for her and say well they had two
seconds to my 20 seconds like I don't
owe them a draw and especially not in a
competition and Anish is doing well with
the black pieces he's blockaded his
opponent's past Pawn those are isolated
pawns for white and you mentioned this
uh in a previous match look at the color
of the Bishops Right light Square
Bishops and white spawns are in light
Square so I think that Anish should go
after those Pawns
yeah
uh he does have the better structure and
if that black king can never come
towards the queen side it's going to be
as
can be very dangerous uh Black's
certainly the one pushing here
you're right though I mean the clock is
so important and uh winning on time is
legitimate because if someone's moving
slower
uh it means they're getting more time to
think about their moves so you should
use that against them but you know
flagging big part of the game in this
game in each you know mate went on the
board but he should look to Flags upon
again because I see the time difference
is six plus seconds Indonesia's favorite
so I don't care what the evaluation is
unless he gives up a queen which he
hasn't just flag him right now
just go for the flag
let's see if he can do it maybe this is
a very important
one to keep an eye on and also blacks
black spawns are making a lot of
progress right yeah now black just might
might just win but even if that pawn is
lost on A2 somehow and he now he's
getting promoted you just this is not
even Shameless you just make random Rook
moves on dark squares and you win the
game
yeah it is a drawn position this
technically in classical chess but
there you go I wouldn't I can I call
that a dirty flag I don't think so
there's no such thing as a dirty flag no
that's wrong to say that in bullet chess
I mean flagging is literally what you
aim to do right it's like you're just
not of course you're not trying to play
the best possible chess otherwise you
would play with more than a minute on
your clock so I think that for a niche
that should get him in the flow but for
oh hanyan I mean he's still even after
that loss he's playing a good match thus
far and he's playing very solidly and
quickly out of the opening stage
so if one side can win this game they
will take a lead in the match
um I really like White's position uh the
White Queen and the white Knights making
a great advancement on the king side
that H pour now gripping the light
squares look at the light squares that
white knight coming into a light where
now the light squares opening up a great
Rook swing here
like defending well though oh I say
defending well but maybe not Robert well
there is no well because the problems
are endless and here just Bishop takes
H6 that's going to lead to a Checkmate
so I think Ohio will just resign
that was a smooth game that was a
quality game uh from a niche so a niche
now ahead in the match and um I mean can
he bounce back in this one
we'll find out but I think when you flag
someone like that it actually can build
your confidence in bullet where you say
oh I had so much extra time like I have
things under my control and that was a
very controlled game just there for
Manish
yeah
and just a bit of news I think in Eric
Hansen's match it doesn't seem like Eric
icy has turned up or may make it to the
game which is good fans for good news
for Eric fans as he might progress to
the next round and we get more Eric
maybe we see more of the his cocktail so
I'm looking forward to seeing what will
be coming out next I pulled up my phone
which I normally don't do on broadcast
but I don't know if people could see it
but that's the game that origin erigasi
is currently in against uh you Yang Yi
so they're still playing in end game
which means that Eric Hansen moves on uh
our generic IC has forfeited because
he's busy trying to defend a classical
game of chess but that's neither here
nor there because Amino hanyan he wants
to even the score Simon I think he's
doing a great job with the white pieces
look at the pressure down the a file in
a protected pass Pawn on C5
yeah he's playing very well here that
pressure on the queen side is good I
mean it does look like a niche is at
least now attacking the White Queen is
rather peculiar on that square it's
trapped itself in maybe it's not a big
deal
nice maneuver of the White Knight here
yeah this is been strange the queen on
H2 not participating but it doesn't have
to when you have a beautiful Knight on
F4 and they're the queen is right back
around but suddenly black has gone for
the attack
evaluation bar really doesn't know where
it stands but it's generally always in
White's favor
if the White Queen can join in it will
be the end and here comes the White
Queen
and I think getting into the position
Anish needs to try some kind of f4 at
some moment like just throw your pawns
forward oh or not just steal the Pawns
yeah oh what look at these tactics here
has to be good for white C7 oh
yeah C7 looks good but he's lost that
ball now oh big check there
big check
yeah it's a win picks up the Rook
um that was nasty by Ohana he noticed uh
the forking distance between the rook
and king and he takes that one with 3.6
seconds to spare so even match Simon I
feel like this has felt very back and
forth where sure there have been some
spoil chances in individual games but on
the whole it seems like four to four and
a half is completely reasonable based on
what we've seen
totally agree
um it's
this opening has been working for a
niche now and I I guess Robert one thing
you get in these matches you have to you
have to feel out your opponent in in the
first like eight games so you've got to
work out where they might be a little
bit weak in the opening and uh where you
should be probing them and maybe this is
something that Fabiano didn't quite do
enough right uh he didn't change his
openings but I I like what a niche is
doing
um this opening seems to be getting in
good positions with the white pieces
yeah you got the note blocking the pawn
D4 and chess bra Eric Anderson says only
way to win I don't think he talked about
two Knights versus two Bishops winning
by four that's still a win we count that
as a dub you move on so uh take that and
enjoy it and we will certainly enjoy
seeing you tomorrow uh playing in your
next match but I think that this game
right here I don't know if it's
enjoyable for either side I feel like
there's so much tension in the center
right now and F oh I do not like that
move you just handed your opponent to
pass Pawn if he goes to E6
yeah it's a blocked position and it's
kind of well known that in Block
positions the Knight is a fantastic
piece and uh
it might look like the black Bishop is
getting quite active but I have a lot of
faith in the White Knight here
I say that and the black king Creeps in
but he's still I still prefer white at
this moment
okay I still if uh White at this moment
no I don't Black's doing well what am I
talking about I'm talking rubbish just
don't blunder a fork and I think that
everything's good but Knight of five at
some moment could be annoying for black
to do it that's why he's thinking do I
go King C3 or not that was a nice move
because that Knight has to stay in front
of the e-pawn
he's squeezing that night there it's
still not easy to win for black
the horns are dropping and just has too
many pawns there and what happened there
was I wrong in thinking that white was
doing well it just changed so quickly
white was doing well and you mentioned
how close board favors the night and he
suddenly opened the board the black king
ran up 10 extra seconds for oh honey and
when that game has ended they're only
eight and a half minutes left in this
match we should remind everybody like we
have been it's win by two and
considering that this match has gone
back and forth It's hard to imagine
somebody jumping out to a two-point lead
that feels like 20. considering how
tight this one has been but with only
just over eight minutes remaining the
players need to keep that in the back of
their minds
yeah
yeah certainly and uh you know it seems
that when one player wins the the other
player just levels the score here okay A
little tactic there and it looks like
white has grabbed a pawn pretty much for
free there it's a useful Pawn to grab
because it actually means you're Knight
and C3 can never get kicked away
uh and this could now be a good chance
to get a little bit of a little bit of a
lead over a niche or a mean one of the
big questions that we always have is you
look at the clock you look at the board
which is more important and I guess that
was a bit aimless by a niche the E4 Pawn
seems like it's loose but now it's not
because then I just plant itself on D5
yeah I think Anish could have got a way
of taking that one but
he decided to play it safe and when you
play the Sicilian as black
playing it safe is something you don't
really have the luxury of doing
now at the right moment white will be
playing C5 here
okay this is another way of doing it
that gets the pawn back now though I
forgot the Rooks defend each other
through the white Rook that felt like a
blunder at first to me
it did but I think a niche has just
blundered there by allowing that a pawn
to become so strong and White's position
is a lot easier to play now you just use
the a pawn to harass black queens this
is
oh oh
I guess you had to do that because the
Rook on A3 was loose but who likes a
rook on G3 this isn't dingley Ren versus
John the Palm machine
yeah
oh Wonder
and the niche going two points down now
okay
oh hi how are you surprising I mean we
look we look to the game and let's just
remind everyone what the score was
yesterday right I mean uh I mean
got destroyed right yesterday but
absolutely destroyed and here is showing
just what he's capable of doing playing
brilliant chess
um
probably a little nod towards Hikaru
there right because Hikaru just went
straight through him yesterday what a
massive score and yeah I think more than
anything as you're implying it shows
just how strong Hikaru Nakamura is in
bullet chest that he beats somebody who
is very talented who's right now leading
against Anish giri 22 and a half to one
half that was insane for lack of a
better word and we see this queen on C3
in these London systems that Quinn can
be in trouble it can be attacked but
it's safely sitting on that square uh
what I did like a moment ago was
anisha's lead on the clock that has
disappeared and it's about a level game
according to the engines
yeah
if Anish loses another one though it's
going to be three down with only about
five minutes to go so it's getting to a
very
intense stage now the niche can't lose
I don't know many more games maybe even
this one yeah you see who would like his
position yeah can't maybe lose any and I
did like it I said native sex watch out
for that discovered that check hitting
the queen on D7
nice spot there
and black does Dodge it and the black
queen now coming right into the Guts and
Black has this dangerous passport backed
up by another black porn Black's
position looking pretty good here
when the Knight is going to D6 the steel
B7 at some point it looks like that
might be uh it protects C4 that Knight
is a hero on D6
is the niche just holding on at this
moment in time
but he is he's up on time as well and
he's gonna win the C Pawn has gone for
it and he's well ahead in the clock I
mean that a niche has been I think the
better of the two in mutual scrambles
I'll give him credit for that but he has
been a bit inaccurate in key moments
allowing his opponent to make draws in
those scrambles
yeah
he's gonna get there on this one we have
about four and a half minutes left and
it's going to be one point in it very
close match but that was a key key win
by a niche he played fantastically to
convert that ending another exciting
Sicilian here
goes into the shreshnikov opening named
after the late shreshnikov he only
passed away quite recently actually
you know what a legend evgeny svechnikov
throughout his career so uh you know
will you have an opening named after you
especially one that's so popular that's
pretty awesome
it is yeah
and the idea of this opening for black
is that black kind of gives up some
positional ideas by getting those double
pawns we saw earlier but gets a lot of
active play and that Rook that's going
to be coming all the way over
a niche going for a big attack here
against White's King white should be
doing all right but it's dangerous look
at the black pieces flying in this is
great play by Niche so far I would have
thought that it was borderline winning
for black you know if I saw this
initially Rook Queen effect or Rook H6 I
mean speaking of geometry and just full
board awareness that was something he
stopped Checkmate in one and by the way
NVR we see you stop trying to give a
Chatter's curse to a niece you were
rooting for him yesterday as soon as you
started chatting it went wrong for him
so give the guy a break come on
he can deserve a little time off from
your curses and jinxes
I think everyone loves the niche really
don't they they pretend not to quizzes
oh oh my words
no emotion on anisha's face there after
falling for a mate in one but
that was brutal
and that could be
that could be the big I mean Envy that's
the mvl curse isn't it yeah
yeah although he just want to piece out
of the opening in this game so in the
timing of that feature chat happen to be
perfect in Maxim's favor but we know
Maxim said that while the previous game
was happening so uh look at this it's a
it's a free piece knight takes F6 D5 you
win a piece and Simon not only should
Anish win this game he's doing it so
quickly that he'll probably get another
game before the match timer elapses
which means he could head into extra
time
as tight or if he loses that next game
that he'll get the match will just be
over
I love what Maxine is saying he's saying
it's not a jinx if my boy is an idiot
brutal that's just brutal yeah
oh that is uh you know I think it's also
Fair yeah
brutally Fair maybe bishop takes H6 at
some point but this is obviously winning
for white White's just got to play
sensible moves and not fall for any
tricks
end of the shot
and I'm looking at the clocks anisha's
keeping a healthy lead on time so
sometimes you get winning positions and
you take a little bit too much time
trying to be perfect but no he's just
finding the tactics he's stealing pawns
he's still up a piece over rookie six I
like but don't get back rank made it
with Rook D1 Rook H1
yeah
every single uh stage so far today it
has gone down to the playoffs and uh it
looks very likely now keeping a close
eye let's remember that when that clock
in the top left gets down to zero uh
that is the end of the match but you
need a two-point lead
and they have another game so what's the
score here so
this means if white wins does he does he
go through is that if I got that right
if white wins here's through if the draw
or a black win we get extra time and we
know what the people want the people
want extra time it's free chess you're
gonna get to sit there and see some of
the best build players in the world uh
combat these games out against one
another but as we see here Amino hunting
he's going for the kill on the king side
yes throwing that Knight in and The Rook
now coming up behind it
um I like this way of playing and he
gets that lovely Square in the center of
the board there
looking fantastic oh this is so
dangerous for a niche now
problem with anisha's position his King
side is now getting scattered and it's
also the center of the board which is
under White's control that's not a move
you want to play okay but really
dangerous here oh he's gonna play Rook
G8 he's barely holding on this crook of
five but the good news for black is if
that Rook moves from F5 the F6 Pawn is
loose but I like that move Queen H3 I
think both sides are handling is quite
oh he put his Queen
he just plundered his Queen Robert he's
dropped his Queen and look at that look
at the reaction on his face
hand over the mouth there
I think he's it's all over it's all over
wow
I can't believe it
and his camera's off an amino hunting I
don't even think he's realized what he
has done here he takes the match against
Anish giri moving on in this bullet
Chess Championship that was unbelievable
yeah I mean it was looking quite tricky
I think it was a well-deserved win
actually uh for a minute in the end he
did play well very close match I mean
it's a bit heartbreaking for a niche
because he's had two matches now that
have really gone right down to the wire
and he's been on the losing side of both
of them uh but it is bullet chess and
this is the kind of blunder that happens
right
yeah often in my games at least Anish it
had to be the favorite heading into this
match Amin Ohanian was not scared one
bit he takes that match by two that's
the winning margin Eric Hansen he was
the recipient of a forfeit Victory uh so
it looks really nice on paper seven
nothing wow you've swept your poor
opponent but it's because our generic
icy did not show up he's playing a
classical game in bill but I I just I'm
having trouble wrapping my head around
that finish there Simon we were promised
what would be extra time exhilarating
you know fast-paced action and the queen
A5 just drops the queen and the match on
the spot
yeah
and it kind of looked like a niche was
sort of turning it at that at the end
they wasn't getting mated immediately he
was trying to get his Queen active but
uh he obviously just picked the wrong
square and um he's gonna be disappointed
it's a big name out of the competition
but what play from a meme after losing
to Hikaru he he's bounced back and he's
you know just defeated one of the best
players in the world well done fantastic
stuff and as we look at the bracket you
will notice something in the losers
bracket you see the four names there
that are made to lose round two none of
them are super Grand Masters their
classical feeder rating is not above
2700 but the four people who were
eliminated Anish giri Dimitri on dracon
Arjun era geissi who did not show up and
Fabiano caruana those are super Grand
Masters so 2700 plus is a Bad Thing
proven in this bullet Chess Championship
and some other players would like to
prove that it's not such a bad thing and
those the players still in the winners
bracket the matches that we are about to
see include the likes of Nakamura Jose
Martinez nerdinsky and Tang that is my
Marquee match of the day Magnus Carlsen
the world number one takes on Min Lei
who is a Speed Demon and a star in the
online sphere and Ali raise a farugia
who won the BCC back in 2021 he takes on
Bortnick strong himself so Simon I mean
we just saw a pretty awesome finish to
that match between Ohanian and giri but
those other super GMS they do not want
to let that go and say oh my rating
speaks for itself
yeah I totally agree and uh well I mean
it was very very exciting we've just
seen the losers bracket and you
mentioned some of the matches to come I
would just like to remind everyone that
we do have this white top match between
Daniel and Andrew Tang coming up also
and he raiser is going to be playing and
we're finishing the day with Magnus
Carson and Karu it's quite quite a good
menu for the day uh Robert oh well I'm
hungry I hope everybody has an appetite
because it's going to be such an amazing
finish to day two and speaking of
amazing stuff and things you will not
want to miss Park Champs five the wait
is over Park Champs is back 16 of the
world's biggest creators will go head to
head in the greatest event in amateur
chess brought to you by chess.com and
park Champs Legend Ludwig watch your
favorite creators like cutie Cinderella
xqc and I did a thing fight for their
share of a 100 000 prize fund and a
ticket to the live finals in LA Los
Angeles use the command POG in chat for
all the details it is POG there will be
POG but right now it's the BCC you will
not want to miss anything here in this
tournament we will be back shortly and
when return it's the winners bracket in
day two of the bullet Chess Championship
2023.
[Music]
thank you
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done 100 AD
free Bliss forevermore whether you're
following our events on site or on
stream type the command connect in the
chat and thank you for helping bring
these shows to life
interested in becoming a chess streamer
like your favorite creators such as
Hikaru Gotham chess and the bow Test
sisters come on look at this
thechess.com Community streamer program
is growing every day
whether you're just getting started with
streaming or already established and
looking to expand your audience you can
now connect your account to chess.com
and have your stream promoted on the
game's largest platform
simply link your account at chess.com
settings slash connected accounts set
your category to chess on Twitch and
start streaming you'll get an ad free
experience on chess.com you will pop up
on our list of live streamers your
trust.com profile will feature your
Twitch stream
and your stream will be linked to your
games on our play server type command
Community streamer in chat and start
growing your stream today
[Music]
foreign
nothing is faster and more exhilarating
in chess than a bullet game it's all
about quick thinking and taking
advantage of every opportunity when it
comes blink and you'll miss it how did
he do that despite his popularity bullet
chess only has one annual championship
tournament and now entering its fifth
year the bullet Chess Championship is
stronger than ever three-time Champion
Hikaru Nakamura again looks to defend
his title and add to his impressive
trophy case a brutal finish Nakamura
officially has won the only player who
has ever stopped Nakamura in this event
also returns to take another shot at it
2021 Champion alireza farugia that's it
competing with these champions for the
first time in the format the best
all-around player in the world Magnus
Carlson has dominated chess seemingly
forever but he's never played in the
bullet Chess Championship will one of
these big three of bullet take home the
twenty thousand dollar crown or can
someone else claim the the title maybe
neraditsky Tang Hansen Carolina
finale in this speediest of speed chess
championships only one Champion will
emerge
welcome to the 2023 bullet Chess
Championship
[Music]
he is the 2021 bullet chess champion
he's one of the best players in the
world one of the biggest prodigies in
chess history he also was a tied winner
of the title Tuesday earlier today so
his accomplishments keep racking up he
is looking to beat alexana Bortnick in
his match Simon alirez afroja will he
get it done
I I think so I think it's going to be a
really exciting match again I mean
Alexander is fantastic bullet player and
we've seen so far that all the matches
have been very very very close so uh I
think Ali Razer will do it but I think
it's going to be a close match he has a
very tough opponent in Alexander we have
two matches uh coming up next because
hey it's fun and it's double the fun
when you have side-by-side matches as we
look at the bracket remind you of where
we're going we have farugia against
Bortnick and you'll see that in the
bottom of the winners quarterfinals and
we also will have Daniel naroditsky
against Andrew Tang Hikaru Nakamura
Magus Carlson they'll come later don't
worry you haven't missed it they will be
playing their matches after the upcoming
two matches but in narrative ski verse
Tang farruger versus boarding I think
fruga is the biggest favorite of the
four but I do really believe that
Bortnick has a very legitimate chance he
is fast and he is good
yeah I agree and I also think any of
these four players who are coming up
have the potential to win the whole
thing uh you know the surprise fund of a
hundred thousand dollars twenty thousand
to the winner it's pretty good not a bad
prize fund and they're they're they all
are bullet experts and on a good day
they could go all the way
I'm with you there and you know we have
had favorites lose already in this
competition we just saw Anish Geary lose
to Amino Han and that was not expected
and for Bortnick I mean he's beaten all
the best players in the world so it's
not a surprise for him to win two three
games in a row but can he sustain it
over 30 minutes that's the big question
but I you know I've been calling out the
whole day the Marquee match for me the
one that I have the hardest time
predicting is Daniel naroditsky against
Andrew Tang because Dania is well known
as a content creator uh he is a very
fabulous commentator he was the 2022
chess.com commentator of the year he's a
good friend of ours but he's also
finished in third place in the last
three bullet chess championships so the
60 million views on YouTube the peak
bullet rating those are fantastic but I
think he ultimately wants to improve on
that third place finish
yeah certainly uh I mean he's he's a
great player he's you see you think he
sees everything so quick but he's also
got all the tricks of the trade right he
knows when to flag he knows when to set
up tricks and um he he can he can sort
of arrange the bullet games the way he
wants to uh his opponent though Andrew
Tang is also an incredible uh bullet
player and also hyper bullet player this
could be one of the quickest matches
we've seen as I think both of these guys
Mouse speeds are just phenomenal uh so
they could be playing more moves than
we've seen in any other match uh I I'm
actually interested to see who's going
to be the quicker of the two because
it's really it's like you know uh it's
like a rocket versus I don't know like
like a bullet it's so hard to tell which
one is quicker because they're both so
quick and this is a two-time bullet
Chess Championship runner up he would
like to win the title for the first time
it's Andrew tang and I looked it up
beforehand they have played it over 3
300 times and penguin GM that's Andrew
Tang he has a slight lead on nerdicky
seven
1743 and a half to one thousand six
hundred twenty four and a half they have
played so many times I don't know the
breakdown by time Patrol whether it's
you know the score has been racked up in
Blitz or bullet but it's very very close
between them and Tang he doesn't always
talk a lot he just lets his moves do the
talking and boy do those moves come out
at a lightning Pace his Mouse speed is
perhaps second to none
yeah yeah I mean he is the star of like
the quicker quicker of the bullet time
limit so the second timer sent uh and
under so um you can just the speed is
phenomenal uh how many moves they can
play so I mean these matches we're about
to say they're just gonna be so close I
mean uh I'm kind of looking in the chat
and seeing what people are saying and I
think everyone's got their fans right a
big following all these players about to
play and let's just remind everyone
after these matches as well we've got
Magnus and the Hikaru playing so the the
day is kind of getting better and better
you know the best the dessert is to come
later on and uh it's just too close to
cool I can't even say who I think gonna
win this one all my predictions have
gone horribly wrong today anyway I
haven't been able to predict anything
right so I think I'll just I think I'll
stay out this one Robert and leave it to
you I mean can you can you predict a
winner in these matches
okay this is gonna be tough I'm gonna go
with farooja I think you know if we're
being honest everyone says furja is a
favorite in that mashup bornick has a
chance but furja is the better bull
player of the two and I'm curious what
the chat things before I give my opinion
in chat you know I don't talk to you
very often but I know you're there and
I'm giving you a little bit of love so
take what you get but let us know what
you think what is your prediction
between tang and nariditsi because it is
oh so close and now that I've said that
you're not going to be swayed by what
I'm about to say I have to go Advantage
tank he beat naroditski last year I
think what we've seen in his return
after graduating from Princeton he
talked about how he went on a month-long
trip with his friends to several Asian
countries including Japan and others you
know he's seems to be in good spirits
and he's returned with a bang so he said
at first he felt a little bit slow he
lost some of his skill uh but it's back
and I think the tank should be the
slight favorite but I'm not saying by
much I mean Daniel nerdinski he has been
the highest rated bulletplayer chess.com
for such a long period of time he's
always up there with the hikarus of this
universe so Simon I'm gonna go with tang
but it's really really close for me
okay well like so you're going You're
Going uh tang and you're going for Ali
Razer to make it interesting Robert I
have to I have to say Daniel and
Alexander then that's uh that's what
we're gonna go for I mean I I don't
really want to bet against Ali Razer
ever because uh
um he's just very good but we've got to
make it interesting I'll go for the
opposite
what are we gonna play for Robert
uh you know next time we're at the pub
you know we got who's uh buying but I
I'm I I this guy on screen here Donya
nerdinski very good friend of ours I'm
he's a monster and I think he really
really wants to win because he knows in
his experience against Hikaru against
Magnus against firoza he can beat them
in spurt so no matter who Tang or
nerdinsky play in the future they know
they have a legitimate chance and on the
left-hand side of the screen we see
alireza farusia he's getting ready for
battle against Bortnick and we're off so
look at the moves they're happening so
fast that it's going to be difficult to
say a word
I was I was thinking the same this is
probably going to be the most com the
hardest ever match the commentator on
the history of chess.com because the
speed they are moving is phenomenal uh
they're already getting quite deep into
the middle game you could even say
closing in the ending here and they
haven't used hardly any time at all I
think the start of the match is going to
be very important though uh if someone
can get a dominating lead their
confidence will grow and that could play
on their opponent as well I mean what do
we reckon so far Robert of the two
matches going on I'm not a mathematician
but I believe that Bortnick is up upon
the left-hand side of our screens here
I'm counting seven for black and only
six for white and two Knights versus two
Bishops hey that Knight on C6 is posing
a problem for that pawn and D4 and well
what part on D4 now it's gone but I'll
erase it he strikes on the queen side go
over the B7 Pawn himself
yeah that one is uh still quite close
but then the other match going on here
um it was looking like Daniel and it
still always looked like Anya has the
pressure because to my eyes the black
king is weaker but Andrew fighting back
now look at that his King comes running
into the center of the board uh it's all
about the past pawns and and this is a
great move creating two past pawns maybe
Black's King run was the wrong idea
there and I think one of these pawns
that white has is gonna become a queen
Daniel very likely to take first Blood
here oh not very likely that one's over
it done it takes game one and you can
see both players they're calm they've
been through this before they lose a
couple games to start uh they have time
to bounce back and Bortnick he is trying
to survive this game but it's not going
to happen you see the clock all there is
ahead he's also about to get a queen
Rook d7s a nice finesse that way the 97
is pinned
yeah yeah that was that was a nice game
there nice game from Daniel he he was
better for most of the way uh there was
a chance to really let it slip a bit
um and I think the other thing these
players need to do they need to find the
right pace is there a danger they could
move too quickly even uh in this one
there certainly is and Diner speaks
about that often uh on his streams where
there are moments when you're pre-moving
when you don't have to and that can
really backfire if you're not
anticipating your opponent's Choice
correctly I could see bornik by the way
shake his head and the other two players
in the in the other match they were
neutral it seemed like okay whatever it
happened but Bortnick he seemed a bit
rattled by that first game so he's going
to need to maintain his composure when
you're playing always afruza you can't
afford mistakes and you can't afford to
not believe in yourself Rouge is a beast
whether or not you believe in yourself
so you might as well have that
self-confidence and hey Bortnick has a
nice position right now
um he does yeah I mean it doesn't look
at your bar for London but he's he's got
a pretty decent position saying that the
dark squares are a bit scary there and
um Ali razor has sacrificed to get some
pressure against White's King side and
we've said this time and time again it's
not always he's got the better position
it's got the easier position to play and
when you're attacking that gives you the
easier option so the evaluation bar
really liking white that could be a
great move there bringing the Knight
around but actually black has the
pressure here I feel that was I thought
an amazing choice about D4 as clearly
there was a mistake Knight takes E4
probably is going to hurt the white King
on each one at some point but he went in
the wrong direction and it looks like
Bortnick wow he Primo Pawn 64 so he knew
that was going to happen and he is
winning according to the engines but not
because of that move
it looks so scary though white is a rook
up but look at Black's Bishops Black's
Bishops are dominating the board and uh
White has to defend very carefully here
and very he does very confidently so
this this could be a big big win if
white can just finish the game off yeah
and look at the clock they're both down
under eight seconds right now white is a
little bit hidden time white can go for
a Checkmate just don't slip and blunder
your queen
oh gosh Rook G1 Bishop E4 was made wow
and this is this is the thing with great
players they make it so so hard and uh
he's got half a second to do this 4.2
seconds when Bortnick wins that game and
he just was like I can't believe I but
he did it that was close
that could be the flavor of the of this
uh this match I feel it could be coming
down to the wire just like we saw there
and it's 1.0 uh in this one and um was
this an ala coin opening quite a um it's
supposed to have a bit of a dubious
reputation for Blackness but maybe this
is what you need to do more in bullet
chess you need to play riskier openings
to to uh trying to confuse your opponent
and even if they're unsounded bullet
chess it's a lot harder to refute them
with all respect to Bortnick his
openings are not his strong suit he
plays his systems he knows them inside
and out so he plays what is not
considered the best line at the highest
levels but he does it with great success
in bullet and Blitz even if it says plus
one for white he doesn't care and
speaking of plus one add one to Daniel
naroditsky's score he is out to a hot
start two and a half over Tang on the
right hand side of our screens
yeah that's a massive start for Daniel
he's looking pretty confident there as
well and again you don't want to let
these matches drift away from you even
though there's going to be many games
played in this game Andrew's got a
pretty solid position Andrew has
actually quite a positional style I've
realized uh it must be a little bit
better now he's going to win a pawn so
this is a great chance for Andrew to
strike back he can either
um well okay maybe not winning a pawn
there but he still has the pressure
against Black's position
yes somehow black hasn't folded
um Dania of course will always fight but
it felt like his position was in the
verge of collapsing and all the pressure
down the C file should pay dividends
here's Rook C6 check yet now
the king's not getting you survive with
a king like that
I mean
that is one crazy King and I just don't
feel Black's King can last here white
must have ways to check make it here
this is where you need your puzzle Rush
okay he didn't find it straight away
yeah I thought I could have won a piece
there but instead he brings his Rook
back first and by the way Bortnick uh
just lost on time in a winning position
so you could see him being displeased
with that result and I think the
left-hand side is going to come down to
the wire of those time scrambles the
right hand side this far seems like you
know each side is really approving their
might in individual wins
yeah and of course looking on the right
hand side Andrew should be winning this
one two pawns up uh but he has three
seconds left and uh we you know that
that's a big big time disadvantage but
Andrew is the quickest player in the
world and there he goes he takes
Daniel's Rook to make the difference
only one point here did you see that
Rook A5 movie so Daniel does this it's
all the best bullet players do this they
know when to try and trick their
opponent they just they kind of scatter
at the moment and okay I'm losing anyway
let me try it but Andrew didn't pre-move
he understood that done it might go for
that and this is why they're two of the
best bullet players on the planet
yeah so it's a nice little 50 50 shot
right you attack your opponent's Rook uh
if they spot it you lose if they don't
spot it you win and it's the kind of
trick you can try it if your position is
so bad anyway uh you have to try a trick
I fall for that kind of stuff all the
time and again my eyes are still drawn
to that match because I'm wondering if
Andrew can now level the score and it's
equal material but now black is striking
and look how open the white thing is
the black queen is going to come in and
it feels again like a great chance for
Andrew to win this this one game here
yeah he's only at one point which is a
bit surprising because it looks like
more but oh no it's so nice he's
training Queens on his own terms getting
Rook to the second rank Andrew looks
like he's getting the job done and he is
winning a rook and I was fascinated by
the other game but bornick in time
trouble and his Advantage is gone he had
an attack no longer and so it looks like
alireza is going to take another one
yeah also that that game you're right
Robert I mean to be drawn to that one
Ali Razer was in a lot of trouble there
and but Nick was attacking very very
strongly but
that's the kind of game he's gonna you
know he really can't lose too many of
them and Ali rays are going to take
another Victory going two points ahead
here
uh close matches though
very very close matches and before we
dive into this specific match I just
want to say that I think it was smart at
Bortnick to test alireza just to see how
his mouth skills are today even though
he was completely losing he probably
could have resigned he's just probably
trying to see is alireza up to the task
and what what is going on in this game
is a king on G3 that is there's a knight
H5 check there but he goes E3 first and
you know how Don is with the tactics
second to pretty much only you know hit
cars of the world
I mean Daniel's played a brilliant game
so far here he he uh found an attack
from nowhere doing an amazing move on
that square there F4 and with the extra
Queen he should be doing well of course
it's always nice to have an extra Queen
isn't it but you can still make mistakes
now the queen moving into the position
but does he have a finish here
he's threatening Checkmate on G2
this was stupid just Bishop takes E3
right and they'll remove the guard of G2
yeah yeah that that that that looks
simple and Andrew
okay he's also made in one wow
that was a brilliant game I don't care
what the time control was that the way
he orchestrated that attack that was
seamless
that was that was quality and if Daniel
keeps playing at that standard he's
gonna be so so hard to break down we
have another sharp position here it
looks like white should be doing very
well here look at the pin on that night
another great move because if that pawn
is exchanged the white Rook is now open
up
and uh opened up even black king too
weak here Robert way too weak the Sensei
indeed I mean that was awesome opening
by Dania by the way alireza faroogia uh
just took another one so he has
increased his lead but the way Dana just
played in opening knowing that Black's
king would be wide open and Simon you're
correctly saying this time after time
that it's often no matter what the
evaluation Bar says and here it said
white was better that if your king is
unsafe you're very likely to lose when
you don't have enough time to calculate
yes it's probably just the most most
important thing at the quicker time
limit it's trying to get your king safe
and uh sacrifices well they become a lot
more dangerous because you want that
initiative white doing well obviously
very well two Bishops better King extra
Pawn uh Andrew is holding on though and
now he's diving in with the last
tactical try
then you're on the defensive a little
bit I you know again I'm pretty amazed
how well Andrew is defending in some of
these games but that fills the game off
winning a piece good recognition from
Diner there and yeah we do have Stanford
versus Princeton Dania having graduated
from Stanford University but look at
Donna he defended G2 he saw the Knight
was hanging and that was that but
I think Andrew needs this one there's
plenty of time left in the match but you
can just feel done gaining Confidence
Game after game
yeah he's spotting tactics just so
quickly here
at night coming straight into the
position but is that night good or bad
there it's in a pin so if the white
knight moose the White Queen is lost
but I don't know I don't like that
Knight it looks very loose there yeah
you're just dropping all your pieces A6
right now probably is good but 98 oh The
Rook at A1 it might be two is it a move
everything was hanging
G5 undermining White's pieces if the
bishop moves away then the Black Knight
will be taken spotting these tactics
just so so quickly so white
has to sacrifice the piece here and I
think he resigns immediately realize
he's got to get more games in at the
moment this lead is getting a little bit
away from Andrew yes just as it is
getting away from boarding I just
watched alireza off the service you can
win another game it's five to one in
faruga's favorite doesn't seem like
bortnick's match but it doesn't seem
like tanks match either the penguin I
don't really know how often the penguin
goes on tilt but it's not tilting in his
Direction at least thus far he needs to
get this game
because
and uh his King's a little bit weak so
we go back to that uh thing we were
saying that maybe uh the valuation Bar
says that black is okay but you have the
king white has the initiative and I'd
much rather be white in a position like
this with the attack and that again is
looking it's looking very dangerous for
Andrew what does he do against that
check
yeah go into an ending okay he has more
chances I feel in an ending he certainly
does because his King is actually
defending against the white Rook so he's
going back and forth these players they
know when to retreat and suddenly the
evil bar is actually suggesting that
black is doing quite well
yeah he needs to pick up a game soon
Andrew
and the bishop a very strong piece in
the middle of the board looking both
ways but you've got to watch out for
that pass Corner white pushing up the
board
and you take the pawn here you can the B
Pawn that must be a winning Ponder but
the Age part is so dangerous because you
can't play Rook B8 because then The Rook
trade would allow H7 and h8 equals Queen
so what is happening at this stage
time situation they're both now getting
very short time who's the quicker player
it's so hard to tell I mean at the
moment Daniel is keeping Pace very well
with Andrew White has the extra Queen oh
my goodness Knight G blocking the Rooks
oh oh you see him pre-moving and you
know it's one of those moments where he
has enough time he didn't necessarily
need a pre-move but it looks like he
should be in time with this queen just
pestering the black king
Robert these guys are insane
I was just looking at those moves and
I'm just thinking how can they do that I
mean what is happening there absolutely
insane ridiculous and I'm watching
Bortnick on the left-hand side of our
screen he just took down farouja in that
night end game so he cuts his deficit
from four to three so we actually have a
four point lead for Dania a three-point
lead for alireza uh Dania saying Robert
don't ever predict against me
yeah yeah I mean Dania is dominating at
the moment and Sport Nick needs to get
back into the match with a couple of
wins as well I think Andrew and Bortnick
are basically in the same situation
right and they they must get a role
going there's 15 minutes left there's
still time
you can see the concentration on
everyone's face Andrew looks so relaxed
in that G4 move we saw Don hit him with
a G5 in the previous game G4 won a piece
for Andrew tang and one thing we noticed
yesterday from Donya is he knows when to
stall like he's gonna lose this game
anyway he might just waste the entirety
of his game clock just to get 20 seconds
off the overall match clock
and you can see the tactics just
happened so quickly here and uh and
you're still making it quite tricky but
of course white has the extra Knight in
this game on the right hand side
piece is flying in the game with alireza
and Bortnick but it looks like Eddie
razor will take another win there
his B Pawn very far advanced
although neither King is super happy the
white was up a piece now it's back to
even in terms of minor pieces but 98
that's a nasty move just bringing in
another attacker
good news to Andrew Tang fangs he did
take that game down and he needs to take
the next one down as well 13 and a half
minutes to go
um the speed is so important added razor
also one of the quickest players out as
you said Robert he's won this event
before let's not forget that what are we
watching on the right hand side of our
screen so alireza uh we know he's
getting the job done but on the right
hand side what is this opening what is
this position whose King is worth Rook
takes A3 and Donna slaps his head
yeah that was a great move from Andrew
he's opening up the white king he's
getting the attack and uh the white king
must be too exposed it's got to be
checkmate with the queen sneaking in
will Daniel waste some time here uh
waiting
uh to resign
I think he shows there's no way that
yeah he should do there's no way the
white king can survive right black
threatening Checkmate Dan you're very
annoyed with that one that game could
affect him a little bit because he was
doing well he had this big attack
as a sip of coffee good idea just chill
out a little bit
and the lead is only going to be two
points there with 12 minutes to go and
we know it's win by two so as long as
the one player is trailing by one point
then they can get more games so this is
a very big game for Dania I think that
you know sometimes like all players he
can go on tilt and he's lost two in a
row and he does not want to see Andrew
find himself back in this match
no
and Andrew must be feeling good as well
after winning a couple of games there we
have the moroxie buying structure this
is basically with white spawn structure
uh the notes that kind of set up
blacks Pawn push
very logical getting play on The Queen
side
Andrew now going to be attacked just
trying to use that F1 to open up the
position
Bishop C8 move was really bright from
Donna because F5 would have come with
the tempo by moving his Bishop back to
see it he gets out of Harm's Way and
suddenly he's trading up he says black
is even a material but the black king is
definitely worse those dark squares in
front of the king and also the F7 Square
for the queen
comes into the F7 square with a big
check there
but and you're doing a great job of
Defending so far
he's playing for the win that's a brave
Choice from Daniel he could have just
taken the draw there yeah and he could
have played Rook f8 just a moment ago
but he didn't do that he is up a pawn so
trades are helpful for him he's probably
going to Queens you said oh okay I
thought he's gonna play Queen G7 and try
to win
do we have a draw there I think it's a
draw we do
okay so back at it they go still a
two-point spread and this opening is
this what we just saw where Don just
stole the A7 pawn and it backfired but
no it's a different variation of the
same line
very sharp stuff that Andrew's playing
as black and more positional is white
and then playing these kind of crazy
lines with the black pieces there's a
lot of players to do this you know
they're willing to take risks when
they're playing with black
counter-attacking but with white they
they want to steady the ship a little
bit
I have a dynamic position sorry this
looks very good for white right Simon
the bishop pair in the center open space
in front of the black king the B2 Pawn
defended by the bishop run D4 and then
did he walk no there's a blunder from
Andrew
yeah
he thought he was spotted the tactic
there but it was a good check from
Daniel and Daniel is now a piece up
and um maybe it's just a good idea to
resign this one I mean you're a piece
down Dania is not making many mistakes
save a bit of time on the clock and get
to the next game
yeah Queen E5 was a nice way to
interpose and that check was blocked and
The Rook on B8 was loose so there's no
choice for the trade Queens so there's
no choice but to resign and so it's a
three-point lead once more still plenty
of time right nine and a half minutes
that gives Andrew ample time to make
this comeback but this variation when
that night with the D6 in the previous
game that did not work out for Android
it doesn't look like it's working out
again
no very tactical here they're both
getting shot positions a little update
on the other match as well it seems that
Ali Razer is I think three points up
there so it's not as big a gap as we may
well it's the same Gap as this match
also a close match and also I'm uh or
Nick to come back into it
although alireza with the white pieces
in this latest game uh looks like he is
taking it in fact he has so that means
that now it's a four point lead for
faruga and Bortnick does not seem very
happy to be there but what is going on
in this game that we see in front of us
it's two pieces for a rook but blast
King looks far safer to my eyes
it does is there any way to Black can
increase the pressure though that that's
a very nice move
and you see Dania he's doing that thing
where he is Checkmate in one but instead
of playing it he is slowing down
Sacrament two rather Queen H6 Queen
takes H5 but he was wasting time forcing
Andrew to resign
cool that was a big game because I think
Andrew should have won that one and uh
every Point like that is massive at this
point in the match eight minutes left
lots of tactics on Daniel's board
against Andrew that Rook has come
straight in
another good chance for Andrew to get
into this match a brilliant move there
he doesn't even take that Bishop in
front of his King he just moves his
Knight in increasing the pressure on
White's position
wow needs to win I think he needs to win
this one right
or is there some nice mate there look
like there should be but yeah Queen H4
and they'd have three checks but what
I'm wondering is like
what went wrong because I'm trying to do
that chest calculation thing when it's
bullet Knight H2 to F3 are you kidding
me
insanely good chess being played by
Andrew in this game this is a fantastic
game
and whop play though the white King has
never found any safety here
what did we just witness look at
Andrew's clock he's up over 20 seconds
and he's playing Pac-Man and taking all
of Daniel's pieces
it's time to get that Hoover out and
just Hoover them off yeah he's hoovering
them
brilliant play Andrew
so that means there's a three-point Gap
and the six and a bit minutes left I
mean I think by my calculation Robert
Andrew probably needs to win every game
now right
and because the clever stalling
techniques of Daniel as well
yeah you cannot afford to lose that's
for sure and by the way there's a draw
on the left hand side of our screen uh
knight and king versus King versus not
enough material to meet so the game
concludes the draw and now it's dania's
turn to have some fun with an exchange
sacrifice oh sorry it's not even
exchange attack first I saw the F2 Pawn
missing for something and I thought it
was like a sack on E3 but now I'm
actually calculating and he's just
crushing Andrew
yeah he's basically Sandra you're gonna
crush me like that and that game I'm
coming at you I want my revenge and um
he has just opened up the white king far
too much here
how many pawns is black up three
you blink and you miss them drop Robert
I mean they just they just go so so
quickly
most of the action is happening in the
opening in these games there goes
another Pawn
so that's four whole Pawns
oh and there's an exchange
well I think it's a whole Rook right I
mean Andrew resigned I think he's got to
resign here but this win might be the
one that's gonna get Daniel through okay
it's a little trick here if you take the
Knight there's a queen h8 Checkmate 81
91. Bang
Bang
and Simon that was the first time I saw
Andrew shake his head I think he knows
that it's about to be over and not for
his whole tournaments double elimination
so Andrew will slide down to the losers
bracket but you could tell that that one
hurt
yeah
yeah I think he realizes you say that uh
the match is slipping out of his grasp
and slipping out of grass we can see the
score on the other one as well and uh uh
slipping out of bought next grasp as
well Addy Grazer is Five Points up with
five minutes to go so also showing his
dominance in the match
I was about to say that if Andrew wins
this game he'll get at least two more it
would seem if he can win it quickly but
he's not really winning this game at all
it looks like Dania is well ahead and he
wants his revenge from a year ago that's
clear Dania came to play today he was
not messing around he left his stream
earlier than I expected last night
because Donna can stream until something
like 6 a.m because I don't know he's a
Madman but he is just destroying Andrew
in this match and a way that I don't
think everyone could have expected
yeah he's playing so well he's got his
magic drink I've noticed as well you
know we saw this yesterday I need to
know what Daniel is drinking whatever it
is
it's uh
you know something I want to get my
hands up on because it's doing the
doing the job well Dania is the one who
introduced me he said that Peter unitos
from the Charlotte chess Center like
says whenever you take a drink you know
that means someone thinks that they're
doing well like when you make you feel
like you made a good move you take a
drink of water you feel confident in
your position so Daniel clearly
confident in his bullet chest he's up 12
to six and he has clinched that match as
far Asia did against Bortnick so
amazing stuff frankly from Dania
just being it's just been too strong
today he's been too quickly he's
spotting tactics nicely and some of the
games he's playing uh I think you
mentioned it Robert we'd be happy to
play I'd be happy to play it certainly
in a Long play game if somebody was
attacking tactics have just been
stunning and he's seen them
automatically
way too quick and here again the pieces
are flying on the board
but it seems like white has worked this
out and white yeah doing well again
and you look at that do you see that
reaction from Donna he knows it's over I
won't say the middle word but it was
let's go and that is a pumped Daniel
nerdinski he is going to move on to the
winners semi-final
100 he's there now as you mentioned
there is another chance for Andrew which
is great news because you know this is
his famous speeches double elimination
also Ali Razer is going to be joining
him uh through into the next round so a
lot of the big names are in this has
been you picked this match as being the
match of the day and it has been the
quality they've both played is
phenomenal obviously Ali Reyes has been
doing great chess as well but it's just
the speed of the tactics which just
amazes me here
I think we're treated like this is a
match where there can only be one winner
that's what happens in competition but I
think we've all won because these two
are such Superstars at bullet chess and
Dania I mean he won this match but we
know that Andrew Tang can make his way
back through the losers bracket uh if
they play again tomorrow the match score
could be flipped that's how tightly
contested their matchups have been over
the years
yeah well said there and it does depend
a lot on the day you know on some days
one one player can be uh completely in
the zone and the other player if they're
just missing a couple of percentage it
will affect them uh greatly and well
yeah as you said Daniel today has been
completely in the zone he's spotting
everything every little tactic is
working his way
even that move he just put his Knight on
the enemy's last rank there right our
enemy's first rank I should say and
that's a great move because it couldn't
be captured and now he's transitioned
into a pawn up Queen ending where he
should just be close to winning
I mean we've mentioned this this time
limit
I mean I mean some people have called it
like the crack cocaine of the Chess
World I don't know if that's a very good
analogy but it's certainly the
I think where you get your adrenaline
going the most because you just have to
move you don't have time to think I
think the indoor things just run through
the body at a much higher rate and
anyone who says that chess is boring you
just watch these guys play and you watch
the speed of their thinking and it's
just phenomenal uh how quickly they can
move and how quickly they can calculate
things
yeah and you see this end game that's
being worked look at that Queen D4 check
give you a little check there Queen gate
you want to keep your pass Pawn but what
Don is also doing is he's taking time
off Andrew's clock and okay this should
be a draw I think that uh it will be a
draw there's no real point of trying to
flag your opponent at this stage but uh
Bortnick by the way also scored a
victory against farrugia so well he did
before and now it looks like he's gonna
suffer a defeat in this game
yeah that is the time over
so we're just seeing the end of that one
and we know now the two players that are
going through
but who have we got next Robert it's not
you know the action is not over the day
right I think you've been most excited
for the matches that will take place you
know we're going to interview for sure
but we will have Magnus Carlsen against
Min Lei and Hikaru Nakamura taking on
Jose Martinez so you thought that Dania
versus Andrew was the peak of today's
performances no no no we have Magnus
nakaru taking part in their matches just
in a bit but this is the last game of
the matchup between Bortnick and farouza
Bortnick is down a couple pawns here
he's down too many points so even
holding a drive winning this game I
won't change the outcome but for alireza
he's been so impressive that we've
barely looked at his match
yeah and look at that you can see what
Nick
uh that's kind of been the way the match
is going very annoyed this blondes his
Queen there I mean it's a hopeless
situation anyway and again Bortnick does
get another chance it's the double
elimination so uh he can get back into
the match but Ali Razer just too good uh
in in that one
yeah there is a fruit earns his spot in
the Winner's semi-finals as did Daniel
noradisky so that was pretty awesome I
mean we were promised some fun matchups
they were a bit more lopsided than other
mashups we've seen But when all said and
done oh there is a farooza Daniel
nerdinski they earned their winning
margins and that means they get to move
on to the winner semi-finals tomorrow
yeah gonna be a great match uh tomorrow
as well these two playing I mean very
hard to pick a winner there uh their
speed has been shown to be in phenomenal
and I would say the Ali raiser and you
know they have kind of a similar-ish
sort of style in bullet chess they love
attacking they love getting the
initiative and when they get that they
they can just calculate through things
that incredible Pace as well uh but next
up as you say Robert the action's not
over we've got the best player probably
of all time Magnus Carlson playing and
Magnus now preferring the quicker time
limits and we've also got the free time
winner of this event Hikaru is playing
and he destroyed
absolutely destroyed I mean yesterday in
the match uh so it's going to be really
exciting yeah hakara forced us to make a
mistake a miscalculation we thought that
maybe Amino hunting just wasn't you know
that strong in both chess but just how
good Hikaru is because I mean beat a
niche today in the losers bracket so
that's what hikara does to people he
makes even the strongest not look that
powerful somehow he is able to sap them
of their strength but we see in the
losers bracket we move on to round two
Bortnick gets to play that very same
Amino and Andrew tank will play it's
Eric Hansen so that's one to look
forward to tomorrow but all eyes I think
are on today we will have an interview
with none other than Daniel the Prophet
nariditski please type your questions
for Donnie in the chat we'd love to ask
him some of yours and when we return
from the break we'll have that interview
followed by Hikaru Nakamura versus Jose
Martinez and Magnus Carlson against Min
Lei you'll not miss any of it stay tuned
from the bullet Chess Championship 2020
three
[Music]
foreign
everybody it's Danny here and as you may
know chess.com and chessable are now one
and I'm here to show you how you can
make your chest.com and chessable one in
just a few clicks to start let's log in
and connect our chess.com account I just
scroll right here above the browser and
click login scroll down and click
continue with chess.com now if you're
already logged into chess.com it's just
going to ask you if you want to approve
that connection I'm going to say yes sir
but after approving it'll bring you
right back to the chessable home page
now the puzzle connect feature can be
found under Tools and you click puzzle
Connect Now what that does after you
type in your username is it's going to
pull positions from the games you've
played on chess.com create your very own
personalized chessable course and then
quiz you with the positions where you
may have missed the best move and the
more you play on chess.com the more
games it will have to quiz you as long
as your account stays connected it's
pretty sweet and it's going to help you
get better learning from the mistakes
you in your games yes this is a pro
feature accessible but if you go to
chessable.com link you can get 30 days
of pro for free
do you wish playing a chess game with a
friend was as easy as sending them a
text well good news now it is but
chess.com's new iMessage app you can
start and play a game directly in
iMessage your friend doesn't even need a
chess.com account it's just tap and play
head over to go.just.com iMessage or use
the command iMessage in chat to learn
more
chess.com's game review recently got a
major update here are four key notes at
the end of each game review you will now
see a summary of the game from your
coach your performance rating for that
game and a quick grade for you and your
opponent in the opening middle game and
in game we've added a new classification
called Miss for when a move fails to
take advantage of an opportunity but it
is otherwise a sound move we've also
changed the definition of blunder now a
move will only be considered a blunder
if it loses material or allows a
checkmate coach will now draw arrows and
highlight squares when you hover over or
click on the highlighted words in the
move explanation this should make move
explanations easier to follow finally
coach's explanations will now reference
specific pieces and threads in
explanations making move explanations
much more intuitive the new game review
experience is available on chess.com
right now
thank you
[Music]
welcome back everybody to the bullet
Chess Championship 2023 a fascinating
round of Chess and we have a very
special guest in the studio for us to
wait a second I'm not compensating
Robert oh my gosh this is two meta well
back to you right
haven't you done enough Donna you just
played an amazing match against Andrew
tank congrats to you that was very
impressive how you feeling right now
I'm feeling pumped uh obviously feeling
feeling amazing I was expecting this to
be a very close match I think it was a
very close match and there were a lot of
jitters you know the first 10 15 minutes
just like there were yesterday but when
I went on that win streak
um all the tactics started flowing you
know all the 50 50 games started going
my way and it was just that's honestly
just what I live for it's super fun
Daniel you you were playing some amazing
tactics uh far too quick for me and um
is there any way you like you you
prepare for a match like this I mean do
you do tactics or you take a walk what
is your secret like secret advice
I wish I had a carefully planned routine
in place that I could share
um it really depends on the opponent
Andrew uh is very consistent with his
opening repertoire uh in it particularly
in bullet chess so I took a look at some
openings I mostly just decided what to
play I didn't really look at it I think
that contradicts the spirit of the
tournament to sit there with stockfish
for hours I did some puzzle rush and I
played a 50-game match with Min Lee
yesterday uh last night so a lot of the
credit goes to Min uh who really brought
the best out of me I got all the
blunders out of the way yesterday saved
like five or six but I can work with
five or six
yeah I actually saw you playing against
man I saw that 50 game match and it
seemed like you ended your stream and
went to sleep earlier than we're used to
seeing from you so how important is the
bullet Chess Championship to you are you
really making concert effort to get your
sleep and get your mind ready for each
and every match
it is incredibly important for me it's
actually one of the most important
tournaments I play in because I actually
think I have a very minor chance of
advancing and doing really really well
and I I want to play Hikaru uh in a
match so I'm forcing myself to you know
skimp on the Netflix and skimp on the 6
a.m streams
um it's you know those hour and a half
two hours that I have in the morning to
just get up shower bring myself to a
good mental space make the seven
beverages that I have on my desk you
know all of that takes a while to
assemble so I honestly think that's been
the key to the kingdom I'm calmer I'm
more focused and I gotta say I'm still
like incredibly nervous before the match
begins nothing replaces you know it's
just hard to describe that feeling when
the match begins and you're on your own
but I do think that my routine has
helped me a lot thus far
uh you mentioned that Daniel that you
you'd like to play Hikaru um that's
going to be one hell of a match if we
see it at some point uh so looking
forward to watching that one and uh I
keep saying you have the same drink and
you mentioned your drink there it is
what what is your drink is it is doing
his job well
I got a I got a battery of various
beverages I'm a big sparkling water
fiend so I go through a different brand
every week yesterday or sometimes every
day so I got a sparkling water yesterday
it was a Waterloo
which is pretty good today it's a spin
drift and then of course coffee like
without coffee I would be
writhing on the floor be beside my desk
and I would not be able to execute more
than three moves before losing on time
so it's coffee it's sparkling water and
you know maybe if I win the whole thing
there will be something else in the last
day
popping bottles of champagne if that
happens but uh speaking of pain it
brings me some pain to read this feature
chat question from Darren and the
question is what do you think of me
predicting that you would lose Andrew
who who predicted that
I did
you did are you Robert hess uh the one
and only Grandmaster let me just take
your address down so I can pay a little
bit of a visit well I think honestly
Andrew has been playing Amazing the last
couple of months and those aren't just
empty
he has been consistently beating me in
30 second matches he's been out speeding
me and that's part of what really
worried me like I was have been really
lost at sea particularly in in the
openings and I think that was a big big
key was I really chose openings that I
was comfortable with I forced him not to
play his samish systems like once once
he put his Knight on F3 I was like okay
King's Indian I can handle that
um and at first I got really nervous we
were tied I lost a couple games but
somehow I managed to flip a switch but
you're forgiving Robert to answer your
question you're still my friend but um I
don't know we'll we'll have to have a
little conversation after broadcasting
you're good sorry I would have predicted
that too again
and another uh question from the chats
Tanya and this is from cebul man and uh
how much of speeches is recognizing
positions versus uh improvising tactics
mostly improvising tactics uh almost
every game goes off the rails at some
point rare is the occasion when you
follow some sort of main line I mean you
can make positional moves in bullet but
it mostly reduces down to oh I see a
cool Square I see the E5 Square my
night's on A1 I'm just gonna telescope
onto that square that that's the extent
of strategic reasoning uh that you have
in bullet mostly it's spotting two or
three move tactics so so important to
avoid one move blunders because that
really kills your momentum and I do
think it's important to go into
positions that you generally understand
that's why I was doing King's Indian and
I was playing the Belgrade Gambit which
which is an opening I've analyzed and
played a ton uh on my stream and it it
really brought me a lot of comfort uh
that we had structures where I knew uh
that I was playing decent ideas but
mostly it is just flash pattern
recognition and almost all games no
matter how they begin ultimately boil
down to who sees more short tactics
and um another question for you Daniel I
mean uh it must be a bit strange being
on this side of the interview but you
mentioned you played Min yesterday and
um you know in a big match and obviously
Mina's now playing against Magnus
Carlson in the next match how do you
think that match is going to go
I uh I have to go help out at a little
chess camp but I'll be watching in the
car and then I'll be watching there I
think we'll all be watching I think it's
going to be an amazing match obviously
men and I are good friends
um he's a tremendous bullet player when
he's on form
um last half of our bullet match
yesterday he was playing like an
absolute champ obviously Magnus is the
heavy favorite the way Carlson has been
playing Blitz and rapid in the last few
months
I don't think God himself can can stop
Magnus but I think it's going to be a
close match I think Min is going to
throw some punches and you know I would
ignore men's feed a rating and the
relative bullet ratings he's a beast and
if he can get his types of positions I
think uh Magnus Magnus will have a tough
30 minutes ahead of him
well Daniel love hearing your thoughts
awesome for you to be on this side of
the interview and we'll let you go you
just said you have to teach some camps
so uh have a great day and we'll see you
tomorrow in the winter semi so uh you
know keep on trucking along
great commentary guys I've been enjoying
it while not playing you guys are doing
amazing and uh thanks again for having
me on
of course done yeah well that was not
just your favorite commentator your
favorite streamer but someone who
advanced to the winner semi-finals of
the bullet Chess Championship that is
Daniel narodeski he awaits the winner of
Hikaru Nakamura and Jose Martinez
alireza farouza got the job done that
was 11 to 5 scores six point margin so
actually not as big of a margin as Donya
won by but it felt like that one from
the early stages was ferruges for the
taking he will await the winner of
Magnus versus Min and Simon it's that
time you've been waiting for it all day
let's be honest the fans they've been
excited for it as well it's the time
when Hikaru and Magnus play they're not
playing each other but they are about to
take part in their matchups here in the
winners bracket of the bullet Chess
Championship
yeah that's right I mean uh two two of
the most amazing players of all time and
certainly of our current generation
you've got Magnus Carlson in my opinion
probably the best chess player ever uh
and you've got the legend of online
chess Hikaru Nakamura who's won this
competition three times and we saw how
good uh for example Daniel was playing
an Ali razor in that last match uh how
can how can you get better than that and
um you know Hikaru uh I have to say is
the best so it's fascinating to see the
best play and I'm very much looking
forward to these matches they're going
to be great yesterday Hikaru had the
best score of the day 22 and a half
points for him that was crazy to witness
he takes on Jose Martinez who from Peru
is living in Mexico as he told us in an
interview yesterday and he was probably
the highlight of day one we put the
spotlight on him because he won that
match in sudden death against Denise
Geary so he goes from one super
Grandmaster foe to another but this is
like the ultimate test for him Jose's a
streamer he plays in title Tuesdays
Arena Kings you name the event he is
participating he has a lot of experience
against Hikaru but if we're being real
when you have experience against Hikaru
it's usually experience losing
yeah there's not many players who have
an experience of winning against Hikaru
um yeah maybe one of the only players is
Magnus Carlson uh and you know the good
thing about these matches though you're
the underdog right if you're Min Lee or
if you're uh Jose you know you you can
you have another chance because you've
got the loser's bracket you know it
doesn't matter so much so you should
feel the pressure but you should also
try to enjoy the match you know realize
if you win you'll be a hero right you'll
knock out a legend and these are kind of
like the sort of lovely stories everyone
uh you know sort of dreams of you know
dream of beating Magnus Carson dream of
beating Hikaru and it's only half an
hour of Chess so it is possible to do
that uh but saying that Robert what are
your predictions I'll put you on the
line again because my predictions today
have been appalling I think I've only
got Daniel right everything else has
gone wrong well to be fair to you you
chose Bortnick because I chose alirez
I'm pretty sure you would have chosen
alireza so you know you're doing okay I
think come on let's be real it's a car
it's Magnus they are the heavy favorites
if you're choosing against them you
better have some uh really good odds in
your corner but Hikaru Nakamura and
Magus Carlsen uh unless the next round
we might be speaking differently I think
for now they Remain the favorites and
let's talk about Magnus first because he
is the world's number one player uh he
joined us yesterday on the broadcast was
disappointed with his win against Eric
Hansen because he didn't fully sweep him
that just goes to show that he wants to
win each and every game there you know
some just he's having fun but Magnus is
the number one rated player in the world
as you said he's likely the best player
of all time and he's won many
championships but not this one this is
his first time in the bull Chess
Championship
I think one of the one of the big
reasons actually for you know it's uh
joining of Chess 24 and chess.com
uh From magnus's perspective is actually
so he can come and win these events
you know Magnus wants to win everything
he wants to prove to the world he's best
at the the quick play time it's the
bullet time limit it's the Long play
title so
don't underestimate how much she
actually does want this competition I
mean he mentioned in the interview
yesterday that uh he's away from home
and he hasn't got his ideal set up so
he's going to be a lot slower than usual
maybe this could play into his
opponent's hands but he is still Magnus
Carlson so I agree with you Robert uh
Magnus and Hikari I mean you just can't
bet against them can you I mean it's
impossible you've gotta you gotta go on
their side they are the favorites and we
do expect them to do well but you just
never know both their opponents are
brilliant players as well and we see Min
Lee here on camera he's got that nice
painting behind him uh he is such a
wholesome streamer if you don't follow
men go do so right now if we can get a
shout out to Min in the chat and Jose as
well you know Magnus you know Hikaru if
you already follow their channels that's
on you you may not be as familiar with
Min lay who is a phenomenal online
player from Vietnam he entered this
competition as the seventh seed but he
also was oh so close last year to
finishing in third place he lost a very
heartbreaking game to date on their
diski he just became a grand master but
he was really a GM at strength far
before 2022 and it's his fourth
appearance in the bullet Chess
Championship he's played against Hikaru
in many different time controls in many
different events but maybe this is one
of his first times playing against
Magnus so that's going to be interesting
is I think he's going to see this as an
opportunity assignment
uh 100 I mean again when you get a
chance to play one of these guys uh
you've just gotta grasp it it's an
opportunity you're playing like a legend
of Chess and even if you are a legend
yourself I'm not saying Lindley is not a
legend he is but you're playing the big
boss it's like you get to the end of the
level you've beaten all the the baddies
except for the big boss you've got this
big monster that you've got to defeat to
level up and uh you know you might lose
once you get another life you're doing
this tournament but if you manage to
beat the big boss it's like
you know it's such an amazing feeling
and uh you know that's the feeling that
everyone dreams of and he can do it he
can do it I mean uh who knows Magnus is
not his ideal setup we saw him maybe
drinking a cocktail yesterday Robert
with Eric so is he still out partying we
don't know but uh it's uh it's gonna be
one hell of a match whatever happens
and yesterday he and Eric were facing
off against one another Eric's match
didn't even happen because Argent Eric
garci was busy playing over the board
but Magnus is now seated I think he is
getting set and ready to play against
minlay he knows he said it yesterday to
us in the interview he knows how strong
men lay is it's not a player that you
can take for granted because let's say
you give Min that confidence he wins uh
game one and then he starts to feel a
bit of Rhythm that's not going to be
good and Don you mentioned this right
plant openings that you feel comfortable
in Min he's known for that he has his
set repertoire he knows how to get these
annoying nagging advantages from the
white side I played men a number of
times he gets his little London system
and he's just like I'm gonna play
quickly and yeah you can equalize but
you also have to equalize in the clock
Magnus can do that but not many others
can
agreed
um and we may defer that's why the first
couple of games are always really
interesting and I think what we've seen
so far is that uh who basically gets
that first Edge
has a big advantage and they're
converting That Into You Know victory in
the mini matches so uh we we can see
them now they are seated it's getting
exciting and they're off
Knights F3 on every board yeah these
they're two very different positions now
because Hikaru went for his B3 system
after starting with Knight F3 and then
we see in the left-hand side of our
screen that Min brought his Queen out
and stole the pawn on B2 so sometimes
that can backfire but look at Magnus
going for a pawn down end game because
he believes the Rooks deserve their open
files
yeah a very interesting play on both
ports and you can see they're quite
positional in nature I really like Mindy
did that you have to be brave when
you're playing these guys if you see a
pawn even if it looks risky if you can't
see a reason why not to take it take it
and actually now the Black Knight also
has a weigh-in Magnus puts his Rook on a
great Square there taking over the open
far
um and it's pretty in the balance at the
moment I feel this game with these two
great players and the other board Robert
also seems quite even at the moment yes
but look at the clock Hikaru is well
ahead on time against Jose and that
could be the problem but Jose's
equalized completely look at this it's a
rook and four rook and four endgame and
here's where Hikaru has to shine has to
just play quickly and has to say I don't
care that it should be a draw Shoulda
Woulda Coulda doesn't matter this is the
BCC
yeah and it's where hikara is so so
strong he can maybe actually uh swapped
off Rooks there and the white king is a
little bit out of play and look at this
Hikaru just coming through the center is
King on a great scrage one one Pawn he's
gonna win another pawn and uh this has
great chances to convert because the
white king is on the wrong side of the
black porn said a bit of work to do here
it might be a draw it is a draw okay is
he gonna try to flag him King and Rook
versus King and Rook why not go for it I
mean Hikaru has more time so he should
do just that and it's what Anish Geary
should have done earlier today
you should have tried and uh he's just
gonna make the 50 moves with four
seconds left Jose he's now got three
seconds remember when it gets to 50
moves it's an automatic draw I hate
getting flagless but she's got points
five of a second he's not gonna do it no
but look at that yes flat Amanda's about
to get flat too Magnus drops a rook Min
late takes game one and Hikaru could not
convert with his time Advantage so
upsets already in the first game of
these matches
yeah I think it was a draw because there
wasn't enough material on the board but
that was that was absolutely crazy and
did you say Magnus lost Magnus lost yes
you know what happened Magnus was better
he was pressing going for an attack and
Min was just the faster of the two
wow Magnus is down on points it's not
often that happens but he's down on
points incredible and also his position
here I do not like as Magnus played this
exact same thing with white pieces and
it's really quite a dodgy position for
black because they're the king but okay
he might be safe now
as the Black Knight has found a great
Square also in the center of the board
wow Bishop f8
calm move from Magnus they were treating
I would have taken the Knight and gone
H4 as black but he says that Knight on
H4 has to stay as a defensive piece and
he takes it any wow a pawn sack he's he
winning The Rook on F2 with Knight G4
okay well Magnus did win the exchange
there and he won it very quickly he
brings his Rook over he can swap off
that Knight at any moment as well and um
Magnus wedding control in this game
looks like he's gonna level the score
there on the other board Jose has a very
dangerous attack here his rook and queen
dominating and can Hikaru defend this
and it's half all there so
beautiful tactics here oh hikaru's seen
that a little bit further Maybe
yeah I think the eval bar you know does
not look like it's catching up to the
players because that was clearly not an
even battle so uh we'll look at that but
we're also looking at Magnus Carlsen
taking game two up 10 seconds and up a
queen for just a night
yeah
and there you go you can see Min Lee
having a little laugh at the end of that
one and we have one all in that match
ikaru is one point up uh after after
that Victory there
and playing very quickly in this game as
well I quite like hikaru's position but
this is also a great move from Jose
bringing his Knight into an aggressive
Square I mean what what could you
suggest what is the right way to play
for example against Hikaru Robert I mean
should you try to Tactical Games should
you just try to play positional does do
these kind of things work I mean when
you ask me what's the best way to play
is just to resign I hit that button I'm
like I'm out of here I don't want to
deal with this this is too much to
handle it's really a question that goes
unanswered unless you just happen to be
a super Grand Master yourself and well
you know party playing it's Magnus
that's also an unanswerable question and
it looks like Min late did take game one
but game two went Max's way and here in
game three magnets up a pawn with white
and he's just gone right to check many
one
oh there you go straight in with
Checkmate and Min well he was showing a
bit of emotion there he's got to make
sure he doesn't let this match now drift
off uh the wrong way uh and okay the
solid opening of this game
and
nice little tactic there from Magnus
swapping off some pieces coming with a
bishop
yeah I was interested that the eval Bar
for a moment there was saying black was
much better maybe he could have delayed
the capture on C3 kept attention with
Bishop F5 first but that's neither here
nor there
this looks solid right this looks like a
position where the quicker player Flags
the slower player because there's no
Pawn tension whatsoever
yeah yeah it's a fairly even position
neither side has any weaknesses that's
also very important uh this we're
talking about in Lee's game against
Magnus Carson and um you know you just
got to make sure you don't create too
many mixes I love what Magnus has done
on the a far though White's B Pawn
behind blacks Queen is a bit weak and
he's just blundered it I think there and
this is the kind of mistake you just
can't do against Magnus and Min now
trying to throw his pawns up the board
to create something on the king side but
it's not gonna be easy to break through
any of Black's defenses in that area of
the board okay well that moved G5
still chances actually from in here yeah
that felt a little bit maybe too
ambitious or a little bit too Carefree
because that G5 Pawn will be vulnerable
now there's going to be a bunch of
checks against the black king at some
moment with a rook infiltrating on E8
and on the right hand side of the screen
it looks like Jose Martinez is promoting
that pawn and you see him he's Bob in
his head Simon he is feeling some
confidence
I love that I wonder what he's listening
to there do we do we have a like well
you know what kind of music do reckon
Jose is bobbing his head to
do you have a favorite choice of band or
music Robert when you're crushing people
online you know it's funny I don't
actually listen to music when I play
chess but I am curious what the chat
thing so chat let us know what do you
believe Jose is listening to I'm sure
some people watch his streams and I'm
just caught in the corner of my eye that
wasn't Magnus you know it looked like he
was better at first now he's holding on
to a draw so Min he's staying right with
Magnus in that match
he is he's staying within grasp of him
that's what you need to do I mean manga
said yesterday as you mentioned that
this he he respects Min Lee a lot and he
knows that he's a great player and this
match is not going to be easy I see some
of the suggestions coming through
um I'm not really with a lot of them I
mean come on come on there's some
there's some bad suggestions here uh I
mean let me let me just I mean we have
gang what's it oh I like the Techno idea
but um
yeah you guys in the chat some of you
got awful taste in music I have to say
gang man style no no no no no no no
insane Cloud Posse no come on guys that
is just wrong uh Abba well you know uh
not for me but anyway yeah Robert
interesting interesting chat we're
getting there
and it looks like
the games are very interesting there's a
king on D6 for men I was gonna say you
know I don't listen to music I was being
honest about that but if I were to
listen to music it'd probably be some
like Leon Bridges I love his music I
feel like it's pretty soothing as well
so it's not like uh gonna get me a
little too amped where I'm not remaining
objective so the eval bars are Sky High
in both these games I think that's wrong
so we are going to a work on that
everybody's apologies just being
transparent here but it looks like on
the left hand side it is actually a
winning Advantage for Magnus for Jose
he's just plotting along in a normal
looking position
yes Hikaru with a two-point lead
um which okay is still within uh Jose's
reach there and uh you know Magnus now
getting a little bit ahead but okay
there's some chances here that Ming Lee
might better draw that game and a lot of
people saying uh how can you like not
like Abba Simon it's not necessarily not
liking Abbott a kind of indifferent
towards them I mean it's very hard not
to like Abra isn't it you have to be a
bit weird to say I hate Abba it's just
when you're playing chess you know yeah
what kind of person hates Abba you know
that's just weird yeah but I think when
I'm playing chess I kind of like a bit
more like upbeat music so like some
something a bit shouty in my ear to get
angry to you know otherwise I'd get you
know Robert you're saying you like it
can't but I get a bit too pacified you
know I need to have that energy so when
I play I just feel like when I get the
energy it's too much energy you know if
I'm like listening to some kind of like
just that beat is just dropping all the
time I feel like I lose focus to some
extent so yeah you see that chat there
anxiety inducing speed uh that's what's
actually saved men in some positions in
this match is he has been the faster of
the two players in some critical down
the stretch moments and we see with the
white pieces this is the minlay system
he just has what seems like a pretty
neutral looking position but he feels
super comfortable putting his pieces on
improved squares
he's one of his players who has that
natural talent I mean Lee where he just
knows where the pieces should go and
that's a really hard skill to learn
there is you know there's not many
players who have that
and he's keeping the score well within
reach I mean it is only one point in it
so one win at any moment he will level
the score I mean seeing Magnus getting
knocked out would be
amazing well he won't get knocked out
but losing them losing would be
did it happen
any believers out there I definitely
love them look at the clock Min is up
seven seconds against Magnus and he has
the advantage in this game and I think
that you know it's the trade-off we keep
referring to is it more important to
have this you know plus two advantage on
the board or have five seconds ahead in
the clock Min is both he just won this
game Magnus looks a bit frustrated this
match is tied
wow tied match between probably the
greatest chess player of all time Magnus
Carson and Min Lee this could go to the
why could we'd be seeing an upset
and uh well we see another position
where the pieces are getting exchanged
quite quickly I Magnus I think will like
this he has the advantage of the two
Bishops in an open structure you can't
take that Bishop's a back rank checkmate
and two Bishops in an open structure
should be a nice edge here but there
goes one of the Bishops but they're
losing a pawn though yeah I mean this is
just the Magnus style right as you were
saying such a position where it looks oh
slightly better for weight he turns it
into an extra Pawn is that extra Pawn
that meaningful right it's a double Pawn
so it's almost like you're not really up
one but he's gonna try to convert this
advantage in the end game
yeah it kind of reminds me of Bobby
Fischer and Magnus Carson like this and
I think one of the best analogies that
someone said when they were talking
about Magnus Carson style they were
saying he was like a a turbo mix of
Bobby Fischer and karpov uh these two
great players they were saying Bobby
Fischer because Bobby Fischer had this
ability to transform positions right he
could take one advantage and transform
it into another Advantage then carp off
because of his positional style as well
and you can see here that Magnus is a
pawn up in this position the evaluation
bar thinks it's a draw
but is he gonna now use that carp off
end game technique I mean the B Pawn
looks really scary
you see Magnum shaking his head he knows
that he's not winning this game but he
probably also looked at the clock and
he's like I'm actually ahead on time for
once and now he's in a winning end game
he is winning wow oh it's shocking but
he missed the win there was it Rook B5 I
think potentially would that would have
maybe that would have won I'm not sure
it's only a draw yeah and this is why
the evil bar can almost be discarded in
these moments but look at the final time
by the way Magnus had 16 seconds so he
could have burned some more clock trying
to find the way through it you know it's
hard to blame anybody when they make a
mistake in bullet but when you have that
lead on time I think you need to pick
your moments to use that clock and right
now that's a game that Magnus is going
to regret
yeah the neck and neck three and a half
all very very close match in the other
match Hikaru taking quite a nice lead
there
um Jose playing good chess but the speed
of Hikaru is just phenomenal isn't it
and that's why a lot of people are
saying Hikaru is the favorite to take
the whole competition again
but first of all Magnus has got to get
through this round if we want to see
Magnus Carlson versus his Karu he's got
to qualify and his position looks really
ropey here that the black king exposed
look at those light squares you don't
want to push Pawns in front your king
too much because you're weaken your king
he puts the Knight on f8 there's the
same Knight on f8 it can't be Checkmate
that black knight next to the king
but still scary for Magnus
yeah that's why he traded the queens and
the Superfluous Knights know more the
knight from f8 is out of there but risky
decisions from Magnus that pawn push he
clearly whoa Knight D6 calculated right
to equality but yeah this does look
pretty level if you just trade off all
the pieces
it looks like well the Black Sea Pawn is
very dangerous but white has an extra
Pawn here
oh son's kid works on the board
interesting mint probably should hide
his King I think that's what the engine
is screaming at him about he's also up
on time so if Min wants to play for a
win I might have tried to flag Magnus in
that position
yeah
floral then neck and neck I just didn't
expect this to happen and the next game
starts Magnus playing the Scandinavian
opening in most of the games
and this is given white quite a nice
space advantage
I I think one of the ways you should try
and Target Magnus is to attack him just
go straight for him
and look at this Magnuson yeah it was me
getting that wrong Robert it was
actually Min Lee who had the black
pieces there no I could tell you about
to be shocked that Magnus would blunder
that I'm also shocked that men blinded
it men almost let that of his chair he
said what am I doing and in such a close
match a single game could be all
important so you do not want to give
Magnus that winning streak we've seen
him do it in tata steel and classical
chess he'll draw his first bunch of
games then he'll win like four in a row
so you don't want him to taste that
blood
100 when he you know he's relentless
he's brutal as well I think to be the
you know one of the best world champions
you just have to be
I mean there you go he's winning a piece
there of that route coming into C2 Min
Lee
laughing about it but I expect he's not
laughing
on the inside there Magnus a piece up
probably best for us to resign this you
still got 13 minutes get to the next
game
I wonder if internally men is just
trying to pump himself up a little bit
because you know at this stage with
magnets with a two-point lead you know
it's in his favor but it's sometimes
hard to resign and immediately play the
next game when you just play at a
stinker of a game so uh for for men he
did just resign he's going back to a
Scandinavian he's where's John
Bartholomew you out there buddy team
scandi is min's preference and it's just
in line with his style he likes to play
Solly he's not a huge risk taker in the
early stages but of course white does
control the center have the bishop pair
and enjoys a small Plus in the white
side the scandi
kind of Suits Magnus as well doesn't it
these kind of positions we're seeing I
mean we're talking about Min Lee and how
it helps him but Magnus likes having a
nice stable Advantage without too much
risk and the problem with the
Scandinavian this variation in
particular is that white always has the
two Bishops and um that light squared
Bishop can be a great piece attacking
like skin
very true and I mean you mentioned good
light Square Bishops I looked on the
right hand side with their car is match
against Jose Martinez Hikaru up three
points and also up it looks like two
pawns on the queen side some would say
he's up one pawn and that is true in
total but he's out up two parts of the
queen side whereas Black's pawns are
doubled on the f file so I think Hikaru
can successfully get this game if not on
the board on the clock
and there you go the a pawn starts to
run
black I did grab a pawn and comes back
and White's winning idea and Kara game
is to get the king to support the white
pawn and he does do that now the
Whiteboard can just try to promote to a
queen there and it's why Bishops are
such great pieces that Bishop on D5 will
start both F and H spawns from its
square and that means the car gets the
game and he increases his lead to Four
Points so it looks like Min has a
winning advantage on the left-hand side
of a screen and a lead on the clock so
he's about to cut that deficit in half
it's about to go from two to one and
just a quick friendly reminder to
everybody watching it's win by two in
the bullet Chess Championship so Min can
stay within a point of Magnus that means
that we could get extra time as we only
have 11.5 minutes remaining
yeah it's fascinating I think Magnus
game could go all the way right only one
point
and we see the chat look at it Min has
got this says I am not Mendes
yeah
I like his position here white white has
a very nice structure Black's born in
the middle of the board is really weak
white has the open file and look at
magnus's Bishop magnus's Bishop is
basically a big Pawn you know you might
as well just call that a pawn he's had
to move it all the way back this is just
take the Bishop Magic recognize it I saw
magnus's face he realized he hung the
bishop and I think this is the problem
when you play something like Magnus you
trust him right you think Magnus
wouldn't blunder let me find a
retreating square that was a free piece
if he saves this game Robert that could
be a turning point you know you don't
get many chances and also Magnus as you
say realize that you blundered a piece
and he's really gonna gain in confident
confidence when he when his opponent
doesn't take the piece uh so I I feel
that minli has to win this game now you
know just to just to stop Magnus gaining
in power it's like Magnus is leveling up
right like uh gaining points every time
he's like okay next level my opponent
can't win the piece
increase in size but
and I mean they're moving so quickly
it's hard to even assess what's
happening but it does feel like Min has
the upper hand he's in an end game up a
pawn
wow they're the Knight is maneuvering
that B4 Pawn is loose but the B3 Pawn
also is a target
still quite hard to win that there's not
much material on the board uh in the
ending you need to keep pawns on the
board and there goes the oh no I thought
another Pawn was gonna exchange you know
the more pawns that gets changed the
nearer to a draw you get and you are
playing the best and game player of all
time that also doesn't help another Pawn
getting exchanged
is that anyway oh look at that that's a
great idea that Min Lee played amazing
technique now I just assumed it was a
draw Robert no I mean he just brings the
Knight back and also he's looking the
clock he wins the bishop but he was also
up several seconds so Min doesn't win
the bishop the first time he takes it he
wins the game and now what do we have
here we have a knotted up match
unbelievable it is six or with nine
minutes to go we could see a major major
upset here uh just a quick update in the
other match Hikaru is quite easily
dominating that match he's nine and a
half to three and a half I really think
we've got to stay with the Magnus
Carlson match as every move it's turning
and now Magnus swinging his Queen over
lining up against Black's King here I I
agree with you I'm not laughing at this
I saw at the corner of my eye Hikaru
brushed it out into laughter because he
was completely losing and then Jose made
a blunder so it's even worse for him now
it's ten and a half three and a half if
akaro wants the spotlight and we all
want to watch her cars games he needs to
stop winning by so many points all right
he needs to give his opponent a chance
and I think that will likely happen when
he faces off against Daniel naroditsky
we will obviously focus on that matter
right now we all eyes are on this game
here between Min and Magnuson has been
even worse he's down upon but that E3
Pawn is the best Pawn on the board
I mean it looks fairly even doesn't it
Robert I mean I it is an actual Pawn but
we have the opposite kind of Bishops and
if the Rooks get exchanged you would
assume it is a draw and now we have
those Rooks coming off
but White's two pawns it's only white
who can win this position that's the
other thing
only white and you're right I mean we we
obviously want to see Hikaru play as
well but you know he he's just winning
too easily that's the problem had his
moment in time it really is and Magnus
is actually winning this end game but I
think he needs to bring his King to B7
he'll put a pushes oh I can't put upon
F5 he loses H7
yeah it's not so easy to win is it I
mean he's gonna try everything because
he wants to get back into lead obviously
but he's a bit down on time uh keep an
eye on the clock here that could be the
most important factor of this encounter
that was a nice move though F6 if the
bishop took h8 equals Queen that's gonna
happen now is this stalemate no because
black sells Pawns
that's why he's the best end game player
of all time and he goes back into lead a
sigh of relief there on his face he
realized just how important that game
was he really really needed it and here
you can keep an eye on the other match
as well Hikaru just about to win another
game I mean you know he's just cruising
at the moment Hikaru
and yeah Hikaru he took that one with oh
no he was white in that game Sorry so he
lost that game sorry for the confusion
everybody uh but he is still just so far
ahead in that match and on the left-hand
side we see mint down one point and
that's the Striking Distance you need to
be in it's win by two in this tournament
and well that Rook to hit B2 that did
not feel good for men
no that's that's a big idea that Magnus
played but he has got his Central break
in this break that mainly played in the
center
often gives white very good compensation
uh and I don't think white is doing that
badly and actually the computer thinks
that White's now a lot better and if Min
Lee can win this one it's equal the
score again with only about five minutes
left
and Magnus stolen each pawn and Min
stolen epon and that King on G8 and
there's a queen in front of it and
there's a past D what is Magnus doing
giving away all of his important Pawns
yeah it's a really weird Pawn structure
that white has the two double pawns but
the pawn in the center as you pointed
out Robert is massive
you could just push it oh baby I
like that part I'm going to see him not
yet with the Rook hanging now on Easter
Bishop E6 oh he's barely escaping his
Magnus
is he escaping this one
for the moment
yeah he's got a block a doesn't he he's
got a blockade on the position and how
do you break through magnus's Bishop
there it's not easy to do you might have
to take the bishop at some point and he
does and his Queen comes in great play
there from Min Lee that was really
clever breaking the blockade and it's
even again seven points oh there's
nothing between them I mean Magnus may
be getting a bit frustrated now he
definitely is he's used to pulverizing
his opposition especially his opponents
who don't have 2700 In classical chess
but that was great play by men even
better called by you because you saw
that coming and Men executed it to
Perfection so we have a tied match right
now as Sakara runs away with his and we
see that Magnus is struggling against
minlay and the black side of another
Scandinavian type of opening here where
the D4 Pawn is a bit of a Target but
white has the bishop pair and maybe is
ready to strike on the king side
there he goes he does strike on the king
side as you say there Robert and uh he
wants to try to get his Rook around but
remember that saying a knight on f8 it
can't be mate we'll find out if it's
true but the Knight next to Black's King
is a fantastic Defender and uh Magnus
also has this weak Pawn I'd say in the
middle of the board so positionally
Black's better but tactically Magnus is
attacking here yeah and he takes an F6
you knew that was coming when he put his
Rook on F4 and so Min sacrifices back
that's often a way to save your king if
you're up some material give some back
and it seems like he's holding on
because as you keep highlighting that
Knight on f8 maybe it's go up to G6 and
where is the Checkmate that you want
it's very hard the king
um comes back maybe you can sacrifice
some G6 that are not sure uh every point
is so key when the match is so close and
there's only three minutes to go
um and look at that it's a big check
there wow what is happening here Robert
it drops a piece he drives a piece about
Rook D2 and the King on G2 is in some
trouble there what's the oh and black
could be winning this
oh he had rooked his Bishop I think that
was the key because the e-pawn would
have promoted it's so difficult to spot
no matter how much time you have but
especially in bullet
and this is such a big game it looks
like Magnus is going to take a one point
lead with about two and a half minutes
left there so this is where if Magnus
wins it you know it is really dangerous
now right uh it's only you know if he
wins a black could be over yeah I mean
this is not one that me can afford to
drop and he had his chances in the
previous game that's what I think as the
underdog you like to see it's not like
when you lose there were some blunders
of course but typically the losses have
been really hard fights and so this
position looks like a Min position
slightly better from the white side
blacks rook's not connected uh but
Magnus is doing a good job of trying to
fend off the pressure on the queen side
yeah White Snake though is looking
really nice isn't it that White Knight
has a stable Square the Black Knight
can't come in because that excellent
last move from White so you're right
this is the main position he he has the
advantage and the queen now diving into
the position he's playing great chess
and watch take this with with the Rook
keeping the open file and now a very
dangerous pass Pawn here
great opportunity
this would level the score again Robert
yeah if he can I didn't love the
decision to trade Queens it felt like
white had all this pressure and now
Magnus is ready to strike with E5
shutting down the bishop on G3 so will
it work white does have F4 and he plays
it to stop it but I think he's going
down the wrong direction
a great Magnus position getting a is
getting much much better here it now
that passport well uh he sacrificed it
and he's lost his Bishop oh my words oh
so that means it's a two-point leap he's
he's gonna get another chance though
Robert
and he must win this is going to be
doesn't win reminder we've been
reminding you all match and all day it's
win by two so if Midway takes this game
we will see extra time and hey this is a
Min like position even if Magnus is the
one who chose the opening it's a solid
setup where men can play quickly
but he has to win Min Lee has to win
he's got the black pieces his position
seems very nice the white Rook is not
developed the white Bishop has to come
out black has some chances here any
other result Magnus is the champion of
this match
and Magnus he's trading off all the
pieces he's a vacuum cleaner he just
wants to say let's get them all of the
board and I'll just hold the draw
because that is what I need and I'm
looking at the clock Magnus ahead there
too
up on the clock and he just grabs the
pawn there quite bravely the Black
Knight coming in to try and cause some
problems
you can see the concentration on both of
their faces they realize how big this
game is the clock now counting down to
zero
black must win
any chances here because
great defensive play so far from England
yeah the really annoying thing is Knight
on each four is trapped over there it
can be used as a weapon at some point if
the queen lands on H2 but Queen G5
trapped the knight in its places on the
rim and you can see Magnus he knows the
match is his ah
wow
that's why he's the champion right
that's why he's one of the best players
of all time if not the best when the
pressure is on and look at that Min Lee
giving him a round of applause there but
you know what Min Lee should be having a
round of applause as well he played
fantastic
let's get collapse from Men in the chat
he deserves it and Magnus Carlson I mean
he knew that it would be a tough match I
don't think he knew it would be this
tough this close but Magnus Carlson he
does what he does best he gets the job
done in crunch time he wins this match
by a three-point margin it really felt
like it could go either way Magnus get a
point lead Min would drag it back down
to level and in the other match that was
never close Simon I mean Jose had a few
nice wins but Hikaru Nakamura he stole
the show in that game
yeah he did and he's done that in both
the matches so far Hikaru has been
absolutely dominant and uh playing
probably the best chess out of everyone
so far that match I don't think Magnus
didn't look so happy with it at the end
you know he realized he just got through
it with the skin of his teeth there uh
and it was it was it could have gone
either way even up to the last five
minutes of that encounter
what a day we have had today let's look
at the updated bracket now that all
matches for day two are done we see in
the winter semifinals it's Hikaru
Nakamura versus Daniel nerdinski Dania
probably the best performer of the day
with that eight point win over Andrew
Tang Magnus Carlson takes down mid in a
close one other Reza faruga beats
Bortnick and so we have showdowns
tomorrow Nakamura neraditski Carlson
farrugia I think everybody should be
circling their calendar for those
I mean what matches do we have there I
mean of course you you have Arrow versus
Daniel maradichi that's that's obviously
a fan favorite but if you can recall
back to when Magnus decided not to reset
and defend his world championship match
he made the statement that he would
defend His World Church championship
match had he be playing and faced
against Ali Razer farooza so he's got a
lot of respect for alireza and we're
gonna see that bullet match tomorrow uh
so wow
tomorrow for sure we also have the
losers bracket players still remain in
that side of the field and we're about
to have an interview with Hikaru
Nakamura so put your questions in chat
we'd love to feature some of them but
for now Simon and I are taking a break
when we return we'll be joined by none
other than three-time bullet chess
champion hikar Nakamura
have a friend or family member who loves
chess gift them at chess.com membership
today and see them take their game to
the next level
choose a gold platinum or Diamond
membership for one month or one year
on your gift to arrive on your friend's
birthday or on a holiday gifts can be
scheduled to arrive up to 90 days in the
future
all premium plans include an ad-free
experience unlimited puzzles and lessons
and unlock all Bots go platinum to add
unlimited game review or Diamond to
unlock insights and Coach explanations
give the gift of Chess today
dude it's impossible to not hear you
just breathing super loudly okay fine I
will hold my breath for three minutes
all right let's go okay let's go right
now just claw cap right here almost
there and you did it
oh what can you do for three minutes my
wife says not a lot but I complain keep
that big butt down dude nice
two one you did it wow I feel better oh
yeah oh you were timing me yeah you were
in there for 30. oh man let's play some
chess and get some dinner let's do it
time lapse yeah okay you bring the clock
oh I left my clock at home dude you
idiot I told you to bring it let's just
go get something to eat okay
oh
download the new chess.com clock app so
you can time yourself playing chess or
whatever other dumb stuff you and your
friends do
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
as always it's a pleasure to be joined
but none other than Grandmaster Hikaru
Nakamura Hikaru congratulations on a win
over Jose you have a lot of experience
playing against him Joshua as he's known
what was it like today and how did you
get the job done so convincingly
yeah I mean I I think that um you know
I've played Jose a lot over the last
couple of years he's always very very uh
very resourceful player I played him
many times in Arena Kings as well as
Blitz and title Tuesday so I knew it was
going to be a tough match
um you know I think really the turning
point was sort of from the get-go I was
able to put a lot of pressure on him in
the first couple of games I think you
know certainly the first game I should
have won that game I didn't um in The
Rook versus Rook end game but the fact
that I won two games afterwards it sort
of set the tone even though I don't
think I played my best chess it was
still good enough so um you just keep
keep moving forward and keep trying to
play well I think the main thing is just
keeping the intensity throughout uh and
never like letting your opponents go on
big streaks if you can
well done
um and is there any sort of advice you
can give to prepare for such an intense
match like this
um I mean I don't think there's anything
specific in terms of advice I think the
main thing is just trying to stay calm
because certainly in Chester there's a
lot of tilt it definitely applies more
to Blitz and certainly to bolt and say
Rapid or classical but the main thing is
always just trying to stay calm because
it's very easy to tilt and lose the game
in like 20 seconds like Andrew for
example in his match against Daniel
there were a couple times where it
seemed like he was getting close and
then like he lost the game and he
instantly lost that next game in like 20
seconds uh purely due to tilt so
certainly the main thing is just to try
and stay calm and not not I'm not not
lose your minds it's very very easy and
bullet because you only have one minute
for the whole game just like Blitz out
20 moves get a losing position and then
just just like that you can ruin the
match so overall I mean I I think that's
the most important thing it's just yeah
just relaxing
well the car it sounds like you've been
following the other matches quite
closely who have you been most surprised
or impressed by thus far in the bullet
Chess Championship
I mean I can't really say I've been
surprised by anybody
um I mean you have the top four players
who are all playing each other so it's
hard to say that I've been surprised um
by anybody you know I I think um if I
had to pick a player though that I that
I would say I've been surprised by would
be uh it would be on each Geary I think
that's because he put up a really great
fight against some Jose Martinez and
then today he was also very close to
winning
um
I get one of them but when you look at
the winners back the top four players I
I mean I don't think that it's a
surprise to anybody who who we have
and uh we we have a question from the
chats here and uh what kind of music do
you listen to when you're playing bullet
chess do you have a particular favorite
kind of band or music
um I mean I think that I just listen to
whatever's on my playlist I mean I I
don't actively pick something different
from what's normally playing but
certainly some some songs are probably
more Up Tempo but it's I just have my
playlist on on Spotify and that's that's
all it is there's nothing there's no
there's nothing special about it um I
just yeah I just listen to something and
hopefully the rhythm's good and I mean I
think the main thing is just not to
listen to something that's super slow I
think like if I were to listen to
classical music during bullet I probably
I'd probably be down like 10 to 15
seconds every game because it's so
boring so I think that's the main thing
is just uh you know just as long as it's
some kind of rock or something a little
bit something that has some Tempo to it
that's important
yeah film The Rhythm which seems in
working to Perfection thus far for you
and we have another question from the
chat uh and the question is
do you prefer to play Magnus or alireza
if you all are to make the final
well I mean for first of all though I
have a very big match against Daniel I
think tomorrow so uh you know I I think
I I said on my stream I would say here
uh as I felt quite a bit in this format
with the time control only being 30
minutes I I certainly think that um it's
very important that you don't get off to
a very bad start I would say that
against Daniel you know it's going to be
a very exciting match like got up to a
good start I think I think I probably
will win if Daniel is hot and I'm not I
could very easily go the other way so I
I think that match is going to be really
exciting
um you know if I make it past that match
I mean
I I don't know who I prefer obviously I
played Ollie Rose a couple years ago I
lost a very very very long like one hour
one hour bullet match I think the finals
if I'm not mistaken um so I do have some
experience playing Ollie Rez of course
playing Magnus was always a lot of fun
so I don't really have a preference per
se
um but I really think due to the format
with it being 30 minutes anybody anybody
can anybody can win it's a matter of the
start the start is super super Critical
with such a short uh time control so I
don't have a preference but it'll be
exciting if I if I make there either way
and just a quick point of clarification
actually the semi-finals onwards are
extended to 45 minutes uh matches so
there will be a little bit more time and
I guess less variance in oh it's my
match tomorrow is 45 minutes yep
okay well that that's I guess that's a
good thing
um
obviously I I just show up and play so I
I don't I don't I don't follow I don't
pay attention to anything anymore
um but uh yeah 45 minutes is definitely
I think a little bit better for me
perhaps I think over a longer longer
period of time I should have have more
more chances to win certainly against
like a player like Daniel but you know
either way I think you have the four
best players are are all all through to
this this portion you know I did want to
say one of things obviously I didn't
have a chance to watch the Magnus match
this was going on at the same time but
uh you know Midway apparently came very
close I think minlay is also another
player who's not as heralded certainly
in bullet but he is a player who's
capable of doing really really well so
just want to give men a big shout out
because I heard he he came very close um
but yeah overall you have the four best
players in the final I think you know
it's gonna be exciting I I don't think
anyone's a big favor I I mean people
might be annoying me for saying because
I think this is like three four years
ago five years ago I think I'm a massive
favorite to beat any of these players
but uh you know as as we all get older
uh things things and times start to
change a little bit so I still like my
chances but I don't think that in this
case there's any one player who's a big
favorite
and another question from the chat here
um so sure repertoire changed much
between uh bullet lit some rapid chess
um I mean I I would say that the the it
depends on the player I think that some
of the openings that I'm able to use say
against Jose or against uh Amino hanyan
for example uh probably would not
working as a player like Andrew Tang uh
very specifically but but generally I
think it's player by player and there
are a couple players where I think some
of the some of the sidelines don't work
as well simply because they're very very
fast
um but overall there isn't there there
really isn't that big of a difference
except for a couple of specific players
where I think certainly when I play some
of the nonsense Sidelines they're very
good I think Ollie Rose actually is
another player will want to play the
sidelines he's very well prepared for
them so some players I try to avoid it
but for the most part there is a huge
difference between Blitz and bull
between classical and Rapid it's it's
massive and I think that certainly
um there are a lot of openings that In
classical chess I would just never never
use and never use a bullet for sure
well speaking of classical chess you
have an upcoming tournament the World
Cup are you excited to head on over to
Baku and you know Slug It Out with the
best players in the world
well I mean I can give you the standard
line which is uh certification from me I
have my my real job as a streamer it's
what pays the bills uh so you know like
like every other tournament including
Norway chess I'm simply going to go and
play and do my best and hopefully I'll
be competitive and that's that's really
the extent of my ambitions if I if I do
well I do well if I don't do well that's
life but I don't really I don't I don't
approach Germans anymore with any of
this any of this nonsense about needing
to win all this pressure all that
nonsense it's just it's just go it's
it's gone by the wayside I think when
you put pressure you have expectations
nothing but bad can come from it
um unless you're magnets I think I think
Matt is certainly is the player who won
this pressure after he's like lost games
he's able to really uh become an
amazingly clutch player certainly but
for me like I and I think for most top
players when you deal with the pr when
you have this pressure you put
expectation on yourself it's all bad
it's all downhill and so I just want to
be competitive and everything else is
just gravy on top
and uh you mentioned the streaming and
you've had some like fantastic results
uh since you've been streaming quite
regularly it has do you think that's
helped your your chest your classical
chess and your results in
classifications
is that I don't think I don't think that
I'm necessarily that much better of a
player per se I think a lot of it is in
the mind at the end of the day for all
of us I think whether you look at myself
Fabiano Anish um you know there's one
player we play against and uh we we all
seem to have bad results and mo most the
times that player plays very well
against us don't don't get me wrong but
certainly you see some of the mistakes
we make again something you don't make
against other players and I think that
sort of sums it all up that a lot of
what happens in chess is very
psychological
um and for me I don't have a lot of the
pressures or worries that I used to have
so
um you know I think that it's helped me
become much more relaxed from a mental
mental standpoint and it's much
different than if I was a pro player I
think certainly if I if I was going like
if I was solely playing trust right now
going to storm I'd be like I'm number
two in the world I have a great chance
at qualifying for the candidates it's
like that's that as a pro player that's
your only that's really the only goal
you have get to the candidates and then
if you can't get to a world championship
match and win um once you've made the
top 10 and so you know in the old days
I'd be feeling a lot of pressure to
perform going since World Cup but now I
mean as I said uh it you know streaming
is much different and much more
lucrative and just frankly better so I
don't have those worries anymore and um
I just play play very carefree and uh it
seems to have made a huge difference I
will say that it's made a huge
difference
well speaking of top level play and
pressure I know you're a huge tennis
fanucaro what did you think about
Wimbledon and alcaraza's performance
yeah I mean I I unfortunately I couldn't
watch it live um unlike unlike a final
that I watched many years ago but it was
actually to be very reminiscent of I
think it was 2008 if I'm not mistaken
the final between Federer and a doll the
the crazy fives that match that many
people consider to be one of the best
matches of all time and um I I think
that it's sort of a start of The
Changing of the Guard um now whether
others come up as well like if I compare
in 2008 I feel like I mean Novak wasn't
wasn't anywhere near where he is today
and I think Rafa was the guy who could
be he could beat Roger at the French
Open pretty convincingly but everywhere
else it was close to close to a toss-up
and then Roger pass of course Novak came
after that and so I think you're
starting to see a Changing of the Guard
I mean it was amazing to see alcoves win
that especially because in my opinion
maybe it's a hot take but I do think
that most likely if not for all the
nerves and the pressure and everything
else I do think alcross would have
probably won that won that match in the
French um so it feels like a changing of
the garden it's an exciting time so I
think kind of similar to to chess in
some ways um you see the same people
winning for a long period of time and
you want to see some of the youngster
some of the up and Conference start
winning and I think it's it's just great
for tennis and really excited to see uh
See who else can maybe break through I
mean maybe all cars are just going to
win 30 Majors or 40 Majors you never
know but you would assume that some of
the other some of the other up and
coming players will break through at
some point as well
yeah well I know one person who probably
doesn't want the up-and-comers to
overtake them that's you Hikaru and
congratulations on your wins thus far we
are super excited to see you take on
Daniel tomorrow so thanks for the time
and another great interview
no problem hope you guys enjoyed it see
you
thanks akaro well that is Hikaru
Nakamura who moves on to take
his part placed in the semifinals in the
winners bracket against Daniel nerdinski
Simon always great to hear hikaru's
thoughts you know trying to remove that
pressure from himself uh but you know he
has some pressure ahead as he's facing
Daniel nerdinski and dania's in the form
that he showed today if he can bring
that into tomorrow's matchup he knows
he'll have his hands full
are you 100 agree I mean Daniel was very
impressive today as well and uh I think
um Hikari may have hit the the nail on
the head there basically saying that how
the match starts is really important uh
it's it's psychological it's also he
said as well and if you can get into a
good role into a good vibe get your
confidence up then that can see you a
long way so I think Daniel to have a
chance he needs to start strong in that
match
for sure and Magnus against color is
that that will be maybe a highlight
match of the entire event and you know
double elimination so no matter who
loses we'll still have another shot and
speaking of this loser's bracket
Bortnick Ohio minlay against paravian
Tang Hanson let's Circle that one as the
fan favorite two popular uh chess
streamers and speaking of Chess
streamers Jose Martinez he had a tough
match today against Hikaru Nakamura he
takes on Dennis lezovic who survived
against Fabiano caruana just when it
seemed like Fabi was getting the upper
hand that was the start of the day but
luzvick he was able to secure his spot
in the second round of the losers
bracket so we will start tomorrow with
the losers bracket and I mean so much
great chess is been underway and there's
so much more great chess just coming our
way no matter where you turn at the
highest levels of Chess at the amateur
levels we've had Blitz Champs and hey we
got POG Champs so POG Champs five is
here it is back the wait is over 16 of
the world's biggest craters will go head
to head in the greatest event in amateur
chess brought to you by chess.com and
pogchamps Legend Ludwig watch your
favorite creators like cutie Cinderella
xqc and C dog VA as well as I did a
thing and many others fight for their
share of one hundred thousand dollar
prize fund and a ticket to the live
finals that's right live finals in Los
Angeles use the command POG and chat for
all the details Simon you know that's
pretty Pub that's going to be a fun
event but you know we also have more
days of the bullet Chess Championship
how do you juggle all these great chess
events
it's tough yeah there's there's so much
great chess now I mean thank you thank
you internet for that
um and the thing that's really exciting
me is that we might be heading towards a
Hikaru versus Magnus final and uh I
don't think that has happened very often
funnily enough in these big online
events and uh that is something I'm sure
uh tens of thousands of people will be
excited to see and uh I'm one of those
people so it's exciting it's really
exciting I mean he's got Daniel in the
way and obviously Magnus has got Ali
razor underway but that would be one
hell of a final oh I mean no matter who
makes it through we're in for a treat we
have four worthy competitors still in
the winners bracket we still also have
an entire losers bracket only four
players were eliminated today so
tomorrow please join us again same time
same place I will be joined by James
Cannon III we'll see Simon on Thursday
and I'll see you all bright and early
for more of the bullet Chess
Championship stay tuned see you then
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]